c'est terrible nokia va tout cas on est
beaucoup sur lui on a fait un raid à 982
personnes quand même assez beau ouais
c'est un grand raid
les gens qui écrivent déjà c'est pas
possible dans le tchat
ils ont un compteur c'est pas possible
il faut rester pour l'installation cpp
et ce au fur et à mesure du stream en
fait ça à l'aider accumule quoi c'est
très marrant comme commande c'est pas
possible
du coup tu faisais des petits pains sur
le sytème de l'ombre genevois cailloux
7-5
le seul qui décide tout ça mais ouais
mais en fait leur ex-équipe l'écran je
joue contre kml à un contre un il ne
fait qu'à rallier 17
je fais damas cinq fugitifs et damages
qui s'y prend bon je dis c'est quand
même dommage tu vois tu veux ma télé je
me sais ce que je dis là en fait c'était
bien ta mise en place avait parfaitement
fr le plan d'adams oui le plan de grève
enfin les plus belles dames cela ferait
après du coup j'étais au courant par
avon tu faisais calais 17 comme karim al
sabah 300 en fait je juge a même pas ce
que fait moi je juge l'estonienne quoi
donc bon c'est un peu moi mais juste je
vais regarder justement a comme dit
mathieu avoue qu elles sont livrées
j'avais le livre j'avais lu donc j'ai
dit ok ya ça et puis du coup j'ai plus
conseillé à certains élèves et c'est
tout dans le chat qui m'a fait rire qui
m'a fait sourire mais je vais te laisser
il répond parce que c'est une question
qui doit revenir et du coup pas en pas
en termes drôle mais les gens me
demander ce que je peux faire un gambit
even sous une écossaise si mon
adversaire ne fait pas eu 5 / 4
difficilement tout essayé à 9h et plus
constamment vous les échecs mais non
vous pouvez pas tout seul en fait donc
faut s'adapter à ce que je l'adversaire
dont vous avez vous bien aimé pendant
que le combi mora sur 4 c 5
si vous fait pas le cas de ces cinq
c'est déjà plus un environnent la même
appellation et puis les idées qui
marchait sur un truc marcheront plus sur
autre chose donc sa cellule en vivant je
suis en train de le montrer à l'écran tu
pourras partager ton écran sinon je vais
surtout eskom et je suis un des deux
joueurs en fait c'est le truc c'est que
si on cadre pas le match et si je
reviens pas c'est qu'en fait pour le
monde joue daeninck une caméra allumé
away madame à zurich avec une caméra ça
ça commence le match phare de recadrer
les caméras je l'avais pas fait parce
que c'est interdit du avec une caméra
donc de base moi je me suis dit ah tiens
il va allumer une deuxième caméra
sinon mais non en fait une caméra suit
bon alors françaises permanentes qui me
fait plaisir
bah oui il a été prévenu mais nice est
ok relativement la mode même des deux à
six mais bon faut pas faire grand cas tu
te fais défoncer c'est le cas de figure
où on peut fermer la position je suis
avec toi fab une puis deux secondes je
t'ai mis le partage d'écran ducouret
c'est bon s y a mais ali ben là tu vas
sortir bat la france avec trois pc 3 2
heures et krishna
donc on va voir si membres c'est
terrible ce bouquin je l'achète pour
pour réfuter le livre son jeu devra
arrêter cette ouverture a écrit shalit
s'il te met des bâtons dans les roues et
tu fais chier fallait soit avec ma
française donc ouais donc tu disais mais
sur grand désolé je vais pas faire les
flèches et en ardèche avec lou deux
pirogues un plan possible à clémence et
kate d1 je pense simplement de faire ces
trois pour renforcer le centre et puis
aussi des fois tu es fou et f2 et le
gaillard 1 0 3 et puis comme ça tu
préférais 5 ou des choses comme ça
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça lasse et je
te poser une question vient ça vient de
quoi ce genre de jeu mais un truc
j'envoie les coins sympas genre de
finale bah je pense c'est un peu mieux
pour les blancs mais ça peut se tenir
aussi donc genre pour les a peut être
une idée de rentrer dans un truc pareil
quoi en fait on se défausse ton gros
défaut ce trucage blanche
si tu arrives à faire genre à 5 bk 3,6
avoir la même finale avec a5b quatre
fois ci c'est parfait ça va
si tu te retrouves avec le mauvais
foulée blanc-bec locales et en d4 machin
tu peux te la faire coller enfin déjà
t'as pas trop de chances de gagner et et
ça peut juste être très chiant donc la
cadence pour expliquer on a on l'a on
l'a pas fait on fait en début de match
pour expliquer il va y avoir une heure
trente où les joueurs vont s'affronter
en cinq minutes plus une seconde par
coup donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
suivre maintenant il y aura après sa 5
minutes de pause puis les joueurs
joueront en trois minutes plus 2
secondes par coup pendant une heure puis
y aura encore une pause de cinq minutes
puis les joueurs vous rend une ligne
christine seconde partout pendant une
demi-heure et à la fin de sa on compte
tous les points et celui qui a marqué le
plus de points et ben il passera au
prochain tour on sera bien sûr qu'il est
plus fort que son adversaire finalement
donc voilà le format fab
je crois que je l'expliqué simplement
note revient exactement ils vont jouer
beaucoup de parties à peu près faut
tabler dans les 25 parties en gros à
quelque chose près ça peut être 22 ça
peut être 28 mai à mai mais c'est aux
alentours de 25
exact bah écoute on va voir duda donc
y'a des fous des trois tables pas très
envie de prendre ce chemin normalement
c'est souvent ni conneries même si c'est
le bon choix
tu es content de l'échanger contre ton
propre fou mais c'est tellement un
danger de se retrouver que tout [ __ ]
cases blanches tout seul contre un
cavalier en face que finalement tu paies
vite et évite donc les noirs soit ils
vont tenter du gepci ce soit je pense
vie réelle qui est de ses six pour
planter un cavalier henri iv alors tu
avales ie7 et le plan d'adams est très
heureux quoi
à la hausse on repense c'est drôle non
mais bien sûr sinon un autre coup que
bombe à la série sera calé à 5 mais
j'imagine qu'il ya des 4 mai khai et à 5
pour rien versé 4 pourquoi pas en fait
on soit du planty prends tu prends en 2d
ouais on fout du coup il devient alors
tour des huit jouer alors je sais pas
s'ils en tête de faire des
être un moment c'est pas facile à
réaliser en général dans de bonnes
circonstances mais qui sait et du coup
et que les blancs bas peut-être tour a
eu un comme ça faty fissile à gérer
parce qu'avec les blancs pas
l'impression d'être mieux avec le
fouquet en baisse à touba et puis tout
d'un coup
grenay il voulait faire que l'eo45
torride
est ok je vais montrer ses cymbales en
retour à 20k valais ouest aura bien ça
empêche mon tour a des seins
ouais gavalda 24 points 4 sur 4 est
lauréat du ku'damm f2 mesdames f2 bien
parce qu'en plus il veut faire d'un
match 4 elle aimait aller exactement il
anticipé la th 6
une autre idée que tu veux avec les
noirs parfois se faire cavaler à 4 m
voilà autre échange les dames s'il faut
mais ta structure toujours doublé ans à
4 à 6 c pas grave tu fixes assez bien b2
il est pas si faible puis 1,4 du coup
j'ai fait car tu m'aimes il n'empêche
ils connaissent tous les plans c'est
insupportable et 17
donc là il a pu si peu il peut il aurait
pu échanger les tabous faire l'essai
échanger jouer la case des quatre médard
h4 sa part est plus fort il veut il veut
jouer l'attaquant fait je pense qu'il a
raison parce que en fait tu pourras
comme jeu qui a valu au cahier des
quatre plus tard
caillé deux peut-être c3 quelque chose
est par contre le roi noir malheur plus
en danger que laurent blanc
donc la raison de garder cette option
peut-être les blancs réimplanter ranque
a lieu deux peut-être c3i pa4 pourquoi
pas en plus tu vas fuir les pions là bas
et à une belle gaz en d4
tu peux te faire f 5 attaquer t'as pas
mal d'options j'aime pas tellement il va
falloir peut-être faire axis assez vite
pour faire un truc parce que je vois pas
tellement de jeux actifs
un truc que tombe bien réglée blanc sait
faire des transferts de tours bien sûr
toi à moi il ya trop de cynisme
du coup m6 et là oui parce que tu veux
mais tu veux tout minet quoi balle autre
idée que lorsque jordan c7 qui est des
six qui est c4 est jolie mais en fait il
fait quoi tu perds trois tentes à créer
un moyen bien placé bon ça d'accord mais
j'adore ça a l'air terrible terrible ah
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi si m6
apparaît pas pas forcément envie de le
faire mais je pense à bientôt et pour le
blanc par des blancs sont alors est-ce
que sur un coup comme tour avant un peu
joint m 5
d'ailleurs c'est marrant que j'écoutais
maxime hier tu sais comme il faisait le
road et il part à l'essai des c6 c5 dans
l'east indienne et c'est qu'il aime bien
faire ces cinq direct parce que
un oubli de sang rapide au moins tu
poses une question enfin genre la tff 5
bon ça va mais en fait oui tu tu mets
tout de suite une grosse pression en
fait pas appel tu sais que c'est
maintenant ou jamais oui quand à la
baisse de 2 points passant intéressant
ce que disent et maxime en blitz tu vois
c'est pas con alors tu envoies et tu
fais quoi en fait
il va falloir se décider quoi tu sais
que c'est un moment important qui peut
nécessiter des réflexions donc de perdre
du temps à la pendule et des choses
comme ça c'est intéressant comme comme
petit commentaire de maxime j'ai jamais
vu la chose sous cet angle là quoi c'est
pas con donc il a fait six comme tu
disais puis on prend tout reprendra donc
maintenant talent pur beurre passe mais
faible exacte dont tu as pu arriérés
mais bon au moins je peux attaquer sur
les quatre dames c 'est tout le truc
comme sa mère ou tour l'autre tour qu'il
y en a 8 ans fait un pion arriver ça va
rarement perdre tout seul quoi cercles
énorme cette pièce pour le défendre
juste le problème soit on sait que tu
dois agglutinés des pièces à la défense
de ce pion et seal alert créé une
seconde faiblesse alors ça peut consacre
indre parce que tu auras moins de
liberté de mouvement pour tes pièces et
voilà mais aussi 100 soit c'est pas
suffisant pour soi la fois j'ai vu une
partie de shorts une fois dans un
bouquin bon ça tu vas ouais ils étaient
ils étaient courts ils étaient courts
ils étaient courts et un moment donné
j'ai pu commencer passé mais ça s'est
fini où il a troqué le pion aux 6 contre
un autre pion il a fait pousser huit
fois ci sous faulx v5 à la fin bientôt
ouais en fait ils allaient mais c'est
très marrant parce que du coup il a pas
gaffe à pas et qu'il fallait la gagner
sur le puriste entre guillemets il a
gagné parce qu'il allait faire ça à la
fin est assez joli timbre est souvent
causés chaque une seule faiblesse ça
perd rarement passe en fait si on a deux
tours une dame chacun de tournehem
chacun bon on va mettre les deux tours
adam attaque du public c'est au tour
szavay la défense du pion et après quoi
et donc justement il faut arriver à pour
attaquer autre chose ailleurs pour avoir
cette liberté de manoeuvre écrit
plusieurs à plusieurs menaces avec 5 est
parti vite bien joué mais la prime était
à la pression sur des 5 1 très
clairement qui a aidé 8 qui couvrent des
saints qui couvre six mais ça peut
tourner un jour
parce que le jour il fera des quatre
tubes et 7 va revivre aussi le pion des
cinq bons ils fouillent sont moches mais
si tu marques ayant dès qu'un cas par an
c'est pas mal donc ouais c'est pas clair
en fait je mets bien les blancs puis
finalement ils doivent tous être mieux
mais bon ça a joué dans le night
n'atteint pas ce que regardent 43 contre
une 03 position tendu là ça va se jouer
à ça va jouer à l'adulte ans donc il est
échangé d'amérique 4 ouais c'est très
tendu comme position peut-être tour f7
way pouvoir traquer les fuites être
comme ça oui c'est souvent bien qu'elle
réfute
quant à ces structures tu couvres binger
6 g/j ch cette dame défi c'est pas mal
aussi parce que tu fous quand il fait
des cas de saddam elle est plus bouché
et elle est revenue trouver du taf ici
bien jouer si dame décide dans le dans
l'esprit c'est un bon coup aussi ouais
je suis comme toi je préfère les noirs
maintenant en fait même mois puis plus
grosses secondes
ce jeu mettra je ferai un petit des
quatre là pour t'empêcher ouais moi
aussi moi aussi j'aurais fait des cadres
ça va partir et il doit exister avec un
relief quatre peut-être ça a l'air bien
aussi les deux sont bien ouais bah kf4
c'est parti c'est bien j'aurais fait des
quatre tempo perso mais je pense qu'à
relief 4 encore plus fort c'est qu'il
prend des trois des quatre commerces
pardon maman donne à temps parce qu'on
devrait y a pas ça non ils n'étaient
tour f 4 way et t4 ensuite décalé là ça
ça coulisse bien enfin les coups je suis
bien c'est fluide pour les normales à
celle là c'est fini je pense pas infinie
tu peux encore la retourne ou quoi mais
je crois que la partie elle a vraiment
pris le tournant pour pour sabine et 3
secondes pour duda qui est un peu lent
je trouve toi qui se fait dans le rythme
ouais à tanger 4 pour finir taf choix
que de raison ou pas pour essayer et apg
2 ça échange
ouais mais là les 2 qui sort qui donne
la date du couple adam ouais alors ça en
longues évidemment ça abandon
blitz parfois à aimait bien jouer dame
sévilla 2 càs de rentrée mesdames c'est
vite fallait le trouver
c'est l'aube à dire tout de suite le bon
bac ou de karwan un voile a sorti une
grosse gallimard d'entrée ouais mais à
trop fort la française quoi bon ça va du
coup le livre peut être mis à la
poubelle avant même d plus krishna livre
de tourner dans grand choix piètre
qualité piètre qualité
du coup une petite un petit et todd may
roxy qui se profile ouais 22 moque de
moscou bon en fait l'idée voilà cette
voie méthode marosi exactement ces
structures mais en ayant échangé des
coups de canne blanche c'est à son
avantage et ce sont des fous en fait
c'est assez marrant
l'avantagé c'est clair que tu es
débarrasser de ton mauvais fouilles et
blanc donc tes centres étaient contents
après en fait l'idée principale
une des idées du détonant existait déjà
pour les avantages des espaces du coup
en fait et changer une pièce mais
n'aurait peut se dire ok au moins
j'enlève mes problèmes
c'est comme j'ai moins d'espacés le fait
de pouvoir fou sinon il n'est pas dans
mes patrons cela imaginez vous ayez un
foot quasiment chaque énorme vous
mettriez ou quoi peut-être un os 6 mais
bon et un qui avait dit que pourrait
venir le prendre ou et donc c'est pas si
mal
donc c'est dur à dire à qui ça profite
exactement les deux camps peuvent être
satisfaits de cet échange et voilà moi
je suis quand même plutôt content avec
les noirs la non d'avoir échangé jamais
son comptoir avec talent et se passe
bah oui c'est ça après bah c'est un plan
genre que sa base au il connaît bien lui
l'adorent comme il joue je le rencontre
il est petit il a gagné de nombreuses
fois avec un cavalier killer c'est donc
le flou de à la fin quoi alagui les
forêts qui sont son mail mbia a laissé
sa place si on devait s'arrêter mais il
en gagne plein des partis c'est
incroyable gagne tout le temps en fait
en partie lente c'est peut-être plus dur
mais en fait comme il traite comme il ya
les bons réflexes immédiatement dans
tout ce qui est rapide ou quoi il va
direct prendre les bonnes décisions les
bons échanges les noms il et il est très
chiant ne jamais jouer ça contre maso et
sur des quatre qui te fait son petit à
petit est indienne et salue retrouve les
mêmes planches
bah f3 il n'aurait pas été content je
sais pas je le sentirai pas contents les
cases noires et où les cases noires à
l'option rage de l'arrêté miot croche il
torée dit je suis à deux doigts de
gagner l'a déjà avec les noirs là il a
besoin de gagner l'amazoo f3 way très
faible joueurs streiff le chauffeur en
fait non franchement cette opposition
séduction et ans et c'est tous les deux
sets
ouais c'est très cool tu ferais cali h5
d'un match 4 fruits 5 avec le pur ou
sept
je sais pas c'est une petite différence
avec eux puis 1,7 et déjà gagnant est
que plus est à deux doigts de gagner
voilà foncé à deux doigts quoi la patte
d'oie
c'est son truc
toutefois dit pas mais j'aime bien pour
les noirs au final la position là il
avait levé 5 e c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour eux tout à fait tu casses
un peu l'étau de marouf dit je trouve
l'activité donc donc c'est pas mal je
préfère les noirs aussi après bon je
dois être plus ou moins équilibrés mais
en tout cas les blancs pas pas
l'ouverture de l'année quoi c'est
étonnant je pensais que ce genre
d'opposition c'est caruana qui
dominerait plutôt parce que parce que
peut-être plus théorique est peut-être
plus dans son style j'avais l'impression
mais finalement tout à la marde très
bien je la structure et il a hélas
égalisé assez simplement finalement n'a
su somme toute sur des dames à cinq voix
3,8 pourquoi pas attaquer le pion à 2
berry sommes satisfaits d'être um
apparaît qu'à 15 ans et 3 pts est un
jour un yes je peux faire mal
tu as le petit pion pion à a2 bon après
les blancs ils ont quand même encore des
pièces active et ils ont l'espace donc
ça doit aller mais je pense c'est genre
de truc qui peut mal tourner assez vite
pour les blancs pas en plus cette chance
et que plomber 4 il te fixes à deux
baies 3 dans ta majorité avec les blancs
elle est un peu inutile après le truc a
surtout pas perdre des quatre sur le
danger alors ce truc là si le calice et
si c'est vous à partir genre les blancs
doublé tour ou quoi
bonjour tu prends b4 du souffle à
l'oreille tu souffles du feu l'un ça va
dépendre de sa taille alenia le commodo
dragons qui est sorti chez presstalis a
vu comment ça c'est un logiciel alors tu
as le commodo et incommodo normale avant
ouais alors maintenant il a des ailes le
logo du komodo adl et ils crachent du
feu est ce qui te mord toujours
accédants seul alors maintenant il te
dit il te brûle quoi il s'appelle le
commodo dragon et je crois que c'est un
mélange de komodo et d'alpha 0 watt
technologies et donc du coup il est
complètement changé les plus verts et
les rouges donc déjà établi très peur et
il a [ __ ] quoi il a des ailes c'est
valérie devient très très dangereux
quoique ovono dragon age penser que tu
avais vu quoi parce qu'il fait il fait
très très peur non je l'aimais hockey et
ça s'achète ce truc là je ne sais pas si
ça ça jette ou pas c'est que tu peux le
dompter tu le mets dans une cache chez
toi c'est sympa avec lui le temps qu'ils
grandissent et après ils te protège high
school is et moulian qui le logo est
magnifique entre israël et très très
beau logo est très bien réussi non mais
en fait c'est clair que s'il avait
vraiment faire marcher ce genre de truc
mélange force de calcul et alpha 0 est
ce qu ça va être assez forte
bahia le stockfisch annen eux mêmes et
ça a eu 6 je sais pas alors je sais pas
si c'était obligé ou pas mais qui ont
des six maintenant ils annoncent plus
200 et l'audit au cra par rapport au
précédent à 8 ans et bah oui il a des
ailes il crache du feu donc fort
qu'avant quoi peut-être qu'il peut quand
même te voir dans s'il en venait
justement de ce crash est donc ok mais
le dragon africaine d'al hilal 0 et ali
einstein et stouff lisa où ils vont et
quand même d'art souffrir j'aime bien
son ode to freeze ouais moi aussi il y
avait pas un as tu pouvais pas prendre
un pion un pion là et c'était quoi le
problème
je mets juste alors dit on va peut-être
juste que vous coûtera pincus mais déjà
comprendre qu ayant des vite j'ai passé
les quatre ans fennecs en fait comme b4
survécu tu te jouer que des pions pour i
ll dame est salle et tour qui rentre sur
la deuxième et sait en plus que les 4
ces particules a renchéri c'est un pote
pour ces deux oui ah oui oui nantes à
tous qu'ils rentraient la maille les
cases noires à deux doigts d'être mieux
ouais quand on va voir
duras je sais pas j'ai du mal à me
mouiller dans cette position en fait
passionnément savoir bien pour les noirs
meta de doigté crouler superbe et 4
aussi donc c'est sûr est dur à lire et
je perdais 6 à tout moment ouais mais
toujours pareil c'est peut-être pas si
grave sur une finale cd4 pour moi la clé
mais je suis pas mais je prendrai la
raison la finale super des six turbines
tour à 8 encore que hier j'en ai gagné
une belle anglaise avec cette structure
mais pas les fous de cases noires mais
j'ai fait c'est le plan avec avec le
pion de plus de 21 euros qui défont du
parfait tu ramènes le roi après tu
passes la tour il défend et puis un jour
tu fais un cas tu fais ton qui ont passé
et tu gagnerais mai mais bon il faudrait
changer beaucoup de pièces pourraient
plus qu'il est fou de cases noires aussi
pouvoir faire ça donc c'est pas se passe
en fait mais je repars avec dans la
finale deux tours si tu prends tu prends
des six elle peut être gagnante pour les
blancs enfin il peut être chiante à
défendre non non j'en vois des fois dans
les houston viennent des trucs comme ça
alors c'est pas tout à fait sur la
position
selestat dna les dangers que prend des 4
des fois tu as des 6 un peu pénible mais
si tu le perds battu le père quoi mais
des fois tu peux est activé en échange
mais georges fenech et une partie qui
est pas mal de je crois que c'est
pelletier contrat confiant je dis pas
n'importe quoi ou en fait pas au québec
les blancs qui gagnent des six mais
après il mais l'or sont tellement active
et qu'ils ont gagné assez facilement
finalement difficile à évaluer
il ya trop de déséquilibres en fait à la
c'est bien joli tour c'est un homme
prend à deux temps français évitent ou
tombent ensuite d'avoir eu dans le sens
où on veut ouais j'aurais fait
transpirer
non mais coûte ça va pour les noirs j'ai
l'impression que je sais pas faim qui
est trop difficile à juger pour moi
solution faire gaffe bouzid pas faire un
joueur de tours b 8 à 4 moi je dis dans
les trucs qui peuvent enfin feria séjour
un jour le pion à deux passants à 4
change complètement la donne à annaba
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs la chance voilà
quatre tempo c'est fini est ce que le
est ce que tu penses que caruana joue
aussi bien que le commentateur français
on va voir un cadre c'est quand même
facile la déco chicken ensilé j'aime
utiliser cette payant bah oui déjà deux
chaises base obligatoire et gisèle
danalyse bon en général à ouattara
stockfisch qui est très bien mais j'ai
aussi bien que toi tu as stockfisch qui
est qui est connu mais en fait c'est
bien d'avoir les derniers cris et les
trucs qui marchent très bien quoi parce
que ben en fait important ton analyse la
puissance des analyses il faut avoir
différents modes moteur pour comparer ce
qu'ils disent non à l'autre et puis
voilà ça coûte pas si cher enfin c'est
pas un cadeau non plus mais bon c'est
hachette un ou deux logiciels ça va quoi
les moyens tu as quoi par exemple
moi j'avais j'avais acheté houdini à
l'époque qui était bien j'avais acheté
l'ofce ce but qu'elle s'était faite
depuis maintenant il me les offres les
mises à jour tout ça parce que comme
j'ai fait des dvd pour des trucs j'ai un
truc un peu inquiet puis saint-laurent
voiture ils sont sympas et comment
rédiger des avantages mais j'avais
acheté houdini je vais acheter le chase
base qui avait à l'époque j'avais plus
jeune j'avais acheté yaars lâcheté venus
acheter les crises j'étais tous les
trucs comme ça quoi et tu comparais quoi
pour en fait je sais même pas pourquoi
tu vois j'ai pas de raison que quand
j'étais jeune je ne lisais pas coiffer
que leur dire mais tu les avais quoi tu
étais content ouais là j'étais content
voilà parti qui tourne bien en copiant
1,4 en appart paribas qui ont pas assez
protégé éloignés c'est plus une
faiblesse en fait au lieu d'être bloqué
par b maintenant ils un jour il pas
fausse
bah ça change tout va être un pion qui
est passé qui est plus une faiblesse en
a deux donc la clé dans l ombre outre m
toutes les pièces qu'ils veulent sur
ecolo n'attaquerons jamais espion et le
problème c'est bon dans toutes les
finales comme tu l'as dit sa pub assez
éloignée donc qui va attirer le roi de
se voter dans les finales est bon je
sais pas si la survie jusqu'à la finale
pour le coup mais met donc aucune chance
à qeynos hâlas il fait mal hein bah
écoute s'il souhaite 2-0 probablement
commence en fanfare ce match joie et
dans parce que les gens disaient dans le
chat que l'ia chess comme il prédisait
67% pour pour duda alors ça c'est trop
ce que ouais c'est trop mais bon on rose
y pensait comme ce que je disais moi
quoi que tout favoris en fait le truc il
n'y aurait pas eu le confinement le coc
vide et cetera je t'aurais dit ils ont
raison et salia le sepa chalco vide il
en aurait eu raison et le fait qu'il est
le co vide le gaz chez lui il n'y a
quasiment pas de tournoi c'est un
événement un peu fan il a vraiment pu
s'entraîner pour bien le jouer la
famille c'est vrai les puits duda on a
vu en norvège n'avait pas l'air trop en
forme
bon il a quand même battu magnus c'était
le premier depuis 125 partie donc ça
reste relatif mais il n'avait pas l'air
pas l'air de jouer aussi bien que ce qui
sait le faire alors après il a été en
forme pour se qualifier parce qu'il a
joué il s'est qualifié via le gros
tournois de californie où il a éliminé à
des gros joueurs notamment car yakine en
finale donc ça ça pouvait compenser on
va dire mais mais oui étonnant fait
étonnant je pense je pense sans le
confinement verra pas un fabiano à ce
niveau là parce qu'il va quand même
impressionné à fabi là puis joue vite
c'est pas son habitude
non mais je vais très bien moi je sais
pas ce qu'il y'a pas un travail tchèque
mur tu as derrière mais sûrement
sûrement tous les jours tous les jours
entraînements
intensifs magnus qui s'est battue lui
même en prenant des risques aussi wef
faut quand même aller se le coltiner
magnus à il est pas mauvaise fille il
suffit pas d'être mieux contre lui pour
gagner il sait défendre moi qui ai c4
intéressant je m'y attendais pas un coup
je regardais dans l'opposition mais même
si au regard de france à expérimenter
c'est pas le genre de coups que tu vois
souvent sur arte voit ses cadres dans la
française cotée blanc ça peut arriver
par ci par là mais mais c'est pas trop
dans dans les genres de couple et blanc
aime bien faire en général ça plombe par
le fait qu'ils vont te tactile et on
faisait vite huit ans après si c'est à
des cinq qui part ou quoi c'est être une
autre histoire mais au final je crois en
fait on le voit plus dans les carreaux
cannes variante d'exactement exactement
exactement
mais il ya une différence en fait c'est
comme le fousseret f5 c'est ça le truc
dans la quarantaine il est plus là bas
va finalement tu vois il va venir en b 7
ou 10 30 les vents quant à part quelques
énarques rendez-vous b5 et compagnie il
est plus là pour pour enlever icloud les
compagnies dont qui peut être mal placé
bizarrement découvert 5 alors que
justement on vante les mérites de la can
comme quoi c'est une française améliorée
parce que souhaiterait que ça mais toi
tu dis faut quoi non les deux ont leurs
avantages leurs défauts mais c'est pas
forcément être sensé améliorer quoi déjà
en termes de structure pions dans la
carro cannes souvent des tenues de
faires des preuves quatre françaises
n'ont ouais mais là c'est logique ce que
fabien non il prend ses 4 tu es fou
bessette moi j'aime bien les noirs en
fait
enfin peut-être que c'est juste et
carlin mais je vais parler avec eux
j'aurais l'impression avec les blancs
d'avoir raté ma position
bats toi ça peut te par les jantes
pression ça être un peu tombé en
quelques sortes dont quelqu'un rit ça me
ça me parle et ça avec quand j'ai les
noirs j'aime bien je sens que c'est
l'élastique qui est en train de péter la
gueule de son adversaire
ok il a tenté le d5 du coup ouais je
pense que là c'est bien joué mais on
jusqu'à voyez b6 et
ouais c'est la logique qui avait six ans
plus tard à rebondir peut-être vers ses
quatre champions c4 ou je sais pas je
signale que changer les dames est aussi
une option mais il sait 4 aussi ré
l'agaci quatre proches à adams et de vue
et j'ai parfois sans défaite fois ci
bien rochelle n'importe quoi les ranger
bon alors peut-être pas de peut-être pas
ou alors qu'ils essaient quatre dom ces
deux écueils trois fois h7 puisque ses
protégés
ouais j'suis pas exempte être s'y
ajoutent les c4 mais c'est pas si clair
ce soir si beaucoup on va dire dont il a
pris vrai bon là toute façon tu vas oui
oui ça suffit de toute façon pour les
noirs je peux citer mieux non plus avec
les noirs mais ça devrait aller a bien
sûr ça va la majorité les pas mal j'ai
fait toujours pareil il paraît enfin ça
c'est vraiment ce truc c'est que dans ce
genre structure hyper important si tu
contrôles la colonne ouverte donc la
colonne des et il trouve selena donc si
je devais donner un petit avantage à
quelqu'un ce serait plutôt la colonia
allait bien bientôt du met mais du coup
se donne un peu la liberté de pouvoir
avancer des pions peut-être là un petit
fois ci ce qui a aidé car qui peut
partir puis ont capturé dix ans et qui a
faim je sens que c'est quand même sympa
pour les noirs mon biquet bon après y'a
toutes les pièces sont encore la bourse
sauf la dame met donc ça c'est un milieu
de jeu compliqué en mai devant un
problème plus et surtour d un tas fou de
foot pro f 3 tours en d2 ça fait mal ça
un complexe serait du coup free retour
autour de moi tout ça me prend deux
tours
il est vieux on prend pas trop le
contrôle de la colonne bas comme tu vois
en fait pour le mans c'est les noirs qui
sont sur la colonne est par exemple à
tour des uns étaient interdits quand
elle première émission une colonne il
arrive que l'on puisse pas de la
contester si facilement ou qu'on doive
perdre trop de temps et qu'on ait le
temps de faire quelque chose en face à
la presse que les bobbies ça arrive
effectivement conclu que ça puisse
annuler que tu es une pour chacun sur
les colonnes et puis puis qui se passe
rien mais en tout cas quand une colonne
ouvert ses importantes pas laisser le
contrôle auto adversaire parce que c'est
une rampe de lancement et de s'en servir
pour rentrer dans ta position attaquer
d'autres trucs dont toi tu seras pas si
et voilà et donc comme l'indiquait vlé
blanc aimerait l'adulé en temps tour d
un mais fait qu'il faut deux bassins
pour l'instant c'est plutôt un truc
point noir est donc le souci c'est que
ben voilà faites-y contrôlable les
colonnes tu vois tu le prennes shirt
variante tactiquement ça peut être
chiant et voilà donc c'est toujours un
truc à faire parce que ce n'est pas trop
quoi faire de vos tours n'ambitionne que
la nouvelle c'est un bon conseil et tour
céder un battant c'est dire déjà c'est
mieux que tous rodez 1 pour le coup tout
à fait mais du coup tu laisses peut-être
ces quatre partiront des choses comme ça
l'annoncé injustement pour stopper ça il
faut récupérer la colonne tu devras
faire une autre concession
donc c'est juste difficile de la
pression probable en feutre et ça peut
faire trois ça peut ça peut vraiment
comme un projet plutôt content fabien
nos joueurs italiens
ça fait plaisir mais ouais la patrie
tant qu'ils mènent qui peut très vite
redevenir américain la tentation pour le
joueur italien est en forme c'est passé
les joueurs que ce qui est c'est fait ça
aurait coûté jours et après sa chute à
bien en forme au début de match de
l'italien aujourd'hui pasqua bas à haut
niveau c'est quoi la vente la plus de la
car aucun n'a pu jouer c'est peut-être
là deux cavaliers n'ont au final bon
récemment c'est tout le truc à la mode
mais
ça dépend des périodes en fait pendant
des décennies s'était essayée 3 ou
queridos paris puis empereur 4.4 où elle
5 kg 3 tout ça bon ça ça a duré pendant
30 ans qui entend peut-être fin des
années 2000 début d'année 2010 était 22
heures avant sa faune ouais début des
années 2000 il ya eu la mode avec
l'avancé qui est c3 et c4 gaspor shirov
jorge sosa après eu l'avant ce classique
et kf3 flow 2 qui a été mis en fait à la
mode il ya longtemps
enfin mis à la mode qui étaient mis au
niveau là il ya longtemps par short en
fait qu'ils aient battu karpov avec 91
peut-être par là et et l'a récemment
plus les deux cavaliers mais donc on va
te soigner des modes et déviée vers qui
reviennent parce que on trouve une
nouvelle idée et aussi parce que les
noirs avaient trop bien à défendre sur
l'autre ils ont valu à les surprendre et
voilà c'est un éternel recommencement
j'ai envie de dire c'est un petit peu
pâquis 83 à nom qui a mis en plus les
deux cavaliers à la mode
ouais mais bannis 83 avec notre max qui
quittait son interprète jean louis
triaud 33 exquise dans le chatt 20,83
d'heure
y'a papa qui est très dur si havas qui
lassé mais après en fait le premier vrai
joueur qu'il avait su fischer oui
peut-être déjà inspiré par baky 83 à
c'est très important je 83 est quand
même important surtout le à doha
il y avait déjà un maquis 83 du coup il
a été obligé de rajouter un aqua
c'est marrant et le nom le nom de c'est
vrai on est non polonais et italiens
comme comme les joueurs du speech est
c'est marrant c'est vrai que c'est les
doodles ça sonne pas si tard il cote
montponnais mais ça sonne pas à toi je
me sens plus pleines et cuits en fait
oui je pense complètement assis vaki 83
il est là je voyais pas ils étaient
parents le chat mais tout de suite
arriver que vous avez peut être raison
ces deux ou trois de suite iv débat qui
est ce que j'aimerais c'est dire je vais
leur mettre des petits baquiast je
repars koné samba qui il a dû se dire
important et puis refaire
non il est quand même là il est quand
même là bas mais là c'est une cata non
père de fou majorité elle dame tout ce
que tu veux
bah ça peut faire trois ça peut faire
quatre ça peut faire ça que ça ça va
faire froid cela dit mathieu qui dit le
président de la pologne seydoux date
hier que président la pun s'appelle
aussi duda qui veut dire j'étais au
courant mais c'est pas trés polonais
sanand femme aurait bon du coup
peut-être que ça fait un peu polonais
alors finalement j'ai fait retirer mon
confrère spécialiste de la pologne qui
l'a complètement alertant sur pression
des patrons polonais oh tu dois de
pointer là bas et où tu vas créer une
révolution en pologne
moi je m'appelle chef qui je vous dis
que c'est pas polonais je me sens plus
légitime serait extraordinaire j'irai
voir cet imposteur
andré landry tout à quai bon bah ça
prend l'eau la concorde ouest en d4
c'est fort surtout rivés foulée 4 donc
là tu prends un f4 tu vas faire un petit
1 tient à droite les deux ou trois 3
tours ses quatre tours c'est rapide
c'est terrible et même sur indre et
loire opposé de façon super grave quand
bien même tu rentres à la photo couleur
opposée en fait
foot est roi et où il farfouille 3 3 ces
cinq mois encore plus faim force et on
web ah ouais ça fait 3-0 et c'est pas du
tout le style de match qu'on attendait
fava ils changent encore el choclo h4 ça
c'est vrai qu'on n'a jamais compris avec
toi non avec cornetto il peut peut être
s'expliquer le truc moi ça me dépasse h
quatre ans mais c'est pas si courant
fait m'auriez dit de la compagnie si
elle existe c'est théorique en tout cas
ouais mais ne jouais pas ça chez vous
non mais là on va comprendre d'où
peut-être parfois je crois tu donc là
pour le coup je peux comprendre une idée
ça calmement qu'il prenne les gélules et
tiens regarde au plafond ou alors lancé
avant les matches avant hktdc de jouer
jouer un coup et moins tu dis à l'autre
qu'est-ce que tu joues pas mais c'est
moche et adra en fait je suis jetée
m'étonnais laquelle tous coupables
soient se joue au meilleur des deux
mondes bongrand votre nom je sais pas on
avait vu une partie à l'époque ans et
sortent est énorme et ce qui est bien
j'étais choquée par ce pays qui est
exactement comme je le rappelle mais je
peux pas jouer ça face à ma c'est vrai
l'encontre de mon avis j'ai mal qu'autre
chose c'est bien joué mais va lui faire
je l'amenais de ferrage 3 je préfère
d'abord là du coup c'est super bien
placé en fait ça va m'apporter bien les
plus touchées savais que tu préfères des
fois je crois cette envie tu attaques
des six puis si tu joues avec 4 après le
purger trois îles et bien voilà tout est
cool quoi mais je pense que tout va mal
réagi au fait simplement il est déjà
moins bien mais c'est marrant parce que
c'est un joueur qui est moins bien
préparés dans les ouvertures et fabiano
il est pas venu pour rigoler un jeu
solide tout de suite
ah non ça va être ça va être compliqué
ça peut être compliqué ça commence à
faire 4 5 0
bon alors après contrairement aux autres
matches puis avait ses scores là le truc
c'est comme tout ça est très fort
intrinsèquement il peut quand même
revenir
vous irez voir venir il ya toujours un
suspens mais bon ballon peut pas prendre
et c'est ce que les dommages subis et
puis on verra après moi j'aurais pris
bon c'est vrai que cette fouille merde
mais comme affaiblir le roi comme ça
chez a priori je suis content quoi chez
pai tard képi qui nous dit ah non pas
que magna d'iquique il est que ces
polémiques qui joue encore qu'un premier
pas fischer à la fin pêcheur n'a jamais
joué à quesnoy enfin pas que je sache
mais jouer les deux qui avait conduit à
carreaux cassés fischer les bottes vinik
j'ai pas je je passe souvent eu quatre
en fait au premier coup donc je suis pas
convaincu ce que dit wikipedia ou
peut-être quotas pas chercher la même
chose c'est flou dont on parle soit
plutôt l'utilisateur qui est pas j'ai
peur que wikipedia raison aussi
je pars que ce soit une chute et du coup
la position b coûte en fait l'euro n'en
va pas être mat tout de suite hein parce
que
parce qu'on a du mal à l'atteindre mais
en tout cas liés aux structures c'est
génial pour les blancs et ça restera
quand même un problème à long terme pour
les noirs ce roi g4 g5 par exemple déjà
way chikhates j'aime bien puisque sur
fou prend il ya deux tours j'ai un clou
ada problème hausse d'un problème local
de chez problèmes aux mains du coup il
fait quoi il fait j'ai 4 e de troc des
règles problemo ce nom là problèmes
associés je pense sur 1 400 il veut
faire f5 et puis g4 g5 à pâques
le plan blanc est clair en tout cas le
retrouver je déteste la position arabe
peut-être que lui a trouvé de meilleurs
créatifs de quoi faire tiens d'ailleurs
j'ai une nouvelle pointe par rapport aux
ce et sinko de baky j'en ai appris plus
hein parce que je le dis joue un peu et
il dit c5 c6 inco dit non mais là je
viens d'en perdre 2 arrête quand tu
perds tu peux pas dire en espagnol c'est
ses côtés
ouais c'est quand tu es bien dans la
position était confiant et que ces
signaux ces étudiants en espagnol c'est
vraiment que tu as deux doigts de gagner
j'adore qu'en fait je dire en espagnol
c'est vraiment signe de grande confiance
mais je j'ai une très bonne position je
peux me permettre de le dire en espagnol
sinon tu peux pas tu dois dire ces cinq
bon c'est un peu mou comme coup quoi bon
je vous sais 5
j'adore fois la petite pointe ouest il
ya une subtilité dans la terminologie
c'est important quoi presque ont dégagé
trois fois je crois où on va verser 4 et
puis on se met la passion de bélier jean
remis d'équerré la tour et faire un g4
cube comme ça tu fais pousser quatre des
cinq ces trois ou même pousser car ces
trois fois 2e et tu repars les deux sont
bons
là ça va pouvoir rester 3 ses plaisirs
aussi est le plus fort de tous ces
cadres du coup on revient pourquoi pas
toi sans sa garde toutes les options
j'ai vraiment adoré la pointe pour le
truc espagnol ça fait marrer du coup je
vais faire aussi maintenant je trouve ça
génial en faire l'écho en espagnol que
quand tu es bien quoi sinon tu portes
français précisément c'est très triste 6
ans j'étais sûr que ça allait de faire
marrer aussi tu as tu va adopter le truc
je pense c'est trop excellent en fait
du coup ce sont ces 500 en fait c'est
comme si tu as le temps ajoutent un
point d'exclamation à ton cou à l'oral
en fait c'est ça va être point
d'exclamation là ok tu hockey ff6
goukoye et g4 et g5 qu était bien quoi
bien sûr on s'est lancé et ça cartonne
ces genres d'annotations orale c'est
beau mais c'est cette affaire fou
détroit où tu vas te faire pousser ses
quatre baies 5 alors qu il ramène on
sait qu'on entend les directement des
trois du coin où tout rejet 2000 mbia
faire car on avait peut-être il est
orange est annoncée pour jeudi c'était
peut-être incroyable tu peux en raison
de ses six sites et un s / / / l'ordre
de coups de l'acca rocade mais ça
mathieu sont sans occuper petits
l'écrire assez de caractère dans le chat
pour lui répondre
c'est faux que de prendre les analyses à
se rendre dès fichiers quoi il va être
heureux analyse raphia les façons d'y
pêcher avec dix villes league alors à 5
mais du coup tu peux repartir en h6 à
tue-tête refaire ce petit tchic tchac
avec la dame et je sais pas quoi ça sert
peut-être péri patiemment fait damage
sicile à faire dans nos salles du majin
damage sein qui va ramener l'autre tour
j'ai vite et que après après tu prépares
roi à 2 c 3 et puis faut 2 et puis je
sais pas l'un dans l'autre je vais y
arriver mais bon ça m'a l'air bizarre
d'aller conseil de marche 5 aussi mais
là il arrive pas il a d'ailleurs fait
ils avaient à se bloquer pourrait
arriver à faire ces 30 noms - c'est fou
c'est vrai est fou c'est qu'à passer
quatre baies 5 n'est du coup pas ce que
n aurions food et cinq autres ont
reproché trop c'est un problème simple
du coup quand une fiche de 3-2 par cette
fois parce que c'est si fort que tu as
juste du dmp 6 des coups comme ça et il
m'a cramé tati les dommages ses soins
adaptés trois heures d'un bassiste d'un
mâle fils dam des huit français
les écoutes s'être ornière déjà on a
passé un premier obstacle et cavaliers
report on ramène la d'amoureux trois ont
détruit quatre est comme ça faut 2 mais
bon bon il est vrai que ces quatre ok on
a dit qu à b5
ouais alors maintenant le truc c'est que
mais là tout ranger de il doit faire fou
des cinq organismes et je pensais tout
reprend g3 vous vous bouffe top français
2-3-2 dimpre en d1 mais peut-être la
preuve cette en fait j'ai oublié haut
débit voire même d'un match si ce nom m
en g3 notamment d'ailleurs c'est à dire
je suis pour les dents de scie et noir
ils sont à deux doigts de maths et de
faire crisser duda main quoi mais bon
ici tu prend qu'une fois en g3 que tu
prends tu prends des 1 wef ou première
recette est peut-être la tour se voir
dire que la tour se barre avoir en tête
comme j'ai un petit peu pas fait ce
qu'il fallait disais au début c'était
sayama table et du coup l'idée qui nous
est venu par la suite serait d'apprendre
en d1 du coup et surtout prend un essai
de vous paraît la tour quelque part
craignant à 8 de base avec qui
tadam juin du coup je sais pas quoi
[ __ ] mais son bâton première écoute
c'est pour ça que rares affiches assez
longtemps en fait rien à calculer tout
ça c'est sûr bad bank en g3 marche pas
en fait alors est du coup très beau noël
pour les blancs dorment ils font des
cinq comme on voulait ça peut être faire
ces trois ans suite à wii fit le fou et
c'est un bon début
est ce que tu fais c'est 3 tu commences
par la maj 6 ou plus en prend 1,4 ça je
sais pas il ya tout reprendre les 4 6
qui peut se regarder parfois mais là je
crois pas que ça fonctionne mais ça peut
être une idée un pur si le pion été
mieux blindés et que l'on pouvait après
récupérer le pion à quatre reprises
prise prise effet repris 24 ça pourrait
lever tour c'est un tour c'est bon au
moins tu évites les tout reproche et 3
et surtout le comble étroiture
production et et tu joues les collègues
à la cola n'est pas prête à plus de ses
3 par contre un briquet en d4 il est là
et bien là
donc tout ça reste compliqué méthode
chez becker mégane à tour ces trois je
pense et il était la plupart en a trois
je sais pas où il y sort ça va pas
inspiré le plus la plus grande confiance
sera g7 mais ah ok j'ai compris son idée
il veut blindé à parce qu'on d'échec
peut-être ou quoi bon écoute chinon
j'aime pas du tout ce qu'il a fait à
riva houle pour marco qu'est l'amérique
et ça c'est n'importe quoi
hier matin je sais pas s'il va se faire
mater ou pas j'ai l'impression qui la
tient mais fab il a raté quelque chose
approche 4 p c'est terrible faby qui a
étonné les vagues et les finalistes pour
prendre cet échange est le plaisir tu
bouges tout début
famille qui s'est raté mais a fait face
c'est n'importe quoi
terrible terrible pour fabiano 3 qui
aurait pu vraiment bon il a quand même
le break mais qui aurait pu complètement
s'envoler avec un 4-0 qu'il avait au
bout des pieds et la place il ya que
plus de genre américains qui déçoit
ouais ouais nous aurait-elle été bien
avec 3 trains sur 3 mais l' écoute jour
et allié américain a fait son entrée en
scène ben tu vois on a senti que c'était
pas du f sinko non américain qui fait
d'avant deuxième décevant toujours dit
que c'était très mauvaise majorque avec
h4
tu vois reçu la preuve je sais pas le
roi est remonté il a pas réussi à
trouver comment mater en fait elle a eu
trop le temps c'était bizarre soit
clientèle en fait c'est pourquoi bon
sens créatif bas c'était bien joué à par
rapport au manque de temps et tout cas
ça complètement surpris caruana et ça va
complètement perdu une bonne chose s'il
avait pu chez paul depuis qu'on s'est
passé exactement mais nobel changer les
dames ouais il a raté quelque chose on
imagine un bon ils reprennent la même
ligne que la propre à participer au tour
d'evil dead 2 en ce cas ça fait 3 il
revient au score et ça peut être un
tournant du match puisque 4 0 et 3 c'est
pas la même chose parce que non mais tu
auras 4-0 ta carrière j'ai senti ma
batterie de ce type un seul instant en
ouverture du masters steam tu t'y si
pascal score de 7-1 regarde
tie breaks dans le premier oui c'est un
match hyper shop hivernale roublev ce
soir exact si roublev qui va qui va se
présenter j'imagine favori roulé pour
moi oui hein
après gaël il m'a dit djoko trop fort
mais bon je peux qui sait qu'il peut le
déboulonner tu peux aller medvedev que
déjà en phase de groupes mais je lui ai
dit pareil moi je dis ouais mais biais
des filets chaud et tout mais djoko je
fais chier
après puisses tu sait jamais c'est comme
nos échecs on n'en sait pour l'instant
c'est pas grand chose intelligente qui
joue les uns contre les autres
oui et non bien sûr parce qu'ils
sourient pas trop à dire djoko te dis
pas non forstmann des grands favoris
tension dans l'air de vraiment respecté
djoko ouais mais je crois qu'il ya c'est
beau ce qui fait djoko depuis dix ans
quand même parce que j'aime à vienne
était un peu dans le dur ou quoi machin
les matches qu'ils voulaient vraiment
gagner
guillaume et il est gagnant peu importe
quoi qu'il en soit il et gagne samedi
s'est vu à mes bons et les autres sont
pas là quand même pas mettre l'eau mais
en fait c'était tu penses que tu es pas
loin en fait sont très très loin quoi
j'ai eu cette balle de match tu n'as pas
gagné j'étais très très loin mais
sûrement ils doivent être loin il va
voir les matchs différemment nous l'ont
fait et ils ont beaucoup de chance
d'être devant et c'est oui incroyable
qu'il soit devant et en fait tu perds
quand j'en sais rien en fait baver sur
nord mais pour djoko c'est pas ma tasse
de thé en général mais j'ai quand même
tirer mon chapeau à l'athlète qui
arrivait à trop du mans mondial depuis
des années des années une parade une
énorme concurrence d'affilée de nadal de
tous les autres donc c'est un
remarquable si faible dans cette partie
du coup ce pas ce nouveau plutôt bien
pour fabien îles fifai le plan dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure le pion des cats le
fou qui rayonne d'un trop fort la
française ouais bah le truc quoi donc le
pion de quatre ans prises mais pas
vraiment puisque sûr qu'il y prend des
quatre équipes en d3 et cette paire une
pièce
et donc avec son coude qui avait lieu
cette fois bible il empêche un peu les
f-5 il ouvre la dgal du fou et puis il
peut revenir peut-être avec lui qui a
aidé 5-3 un moment quoi donc
il a pas mal de bonnes idées plus en
plus les dames qui peut devenir pourri
pour les blancs après des prêts à 3 v
prend 1,3 du dam b2 des machins comme ça
je sais pas quand mais ouais pourquoi
pas s'il pouvait prendre des quatre
effectué en fait donc oui on est déjà
directeur
pourquoi pas après farina f5 modem b2 du
qooq
bat a probablement raison que les
plantations des bévues pas rester à rien
faire et se faire bouffer tous les pions
il faut tenter et 5e derrière bouquet
iasi 4 c'est clair on jouer en ce sens
ça prépare est de 5 pour planter
quelques mètres 5 puis une dame en g3 et
puis et puis aller dîner en ville c'est
pas si clair je pense sa position tête
g6 mais bon ça donne tellement vitrifiés
mais bon j'ai si ces mesures solides car
à 10 h 5
sa part de marché maxi parle de qui et
prend des trois tours ces deux c'est
bien aussi ce qui est pour les 3,6
prennent du plomb les blanches que le
final était assez dur avec les nerfs ils
s'y prennent de la tour du coup est
assez vite c'est bien aussi à tour c'est
d'abord aux quais bas il veut prendre
les trois prochains coups donc ils
préparent est ce que je fais car et h5
qui a aidé trois dames g3 et du coup je
prendrais du pion mais il serait pas
échangé les dames c'est con
pas mal peu d'autres effectivement
effectivement c'est un truc bien
facilement c'est une idée bah non c'est
pas qu'on arrête ça l'air intelligent vu
parce que prendre de la tour en d3 bon
tu vas perdre ses deux bons après vous
pire tu all in mais bon ca pue et pas ce
qui me fait perdre une option ces deux
déjà température en soit mon buste ag2
qui vont être faites chauffer les frais
ça toute la merde trop que de balle
perdent c'est très plaisir donc versé
prend des 3 pourquoi pas et ça te
permettra pas de bla des cailloux quatre
plus tard je sais pas faim tant qu'à
faire
c'est quand même mais en option et donc
donc c'est bien ton truc que moi ça te
permet de garder tout ça ce corps de
rêve contre duda caruana je n'ai pas 20
0 pour eux partagent pas ce point mais
oui enfin il y aurait pas de match enfin
il n'y a pas qu'en diriez pas de doute
sur l'issue du match devant jours avait
quand même quatre heures pour être bien
sûr là bas il n'y a pas doute mais quand
même
laisse moi et ce bien sûr qu'on va venir
bright sûr quand même donc je sens qu'il
va lui faire ça donc c'est aussi clair
du coup de pied pour les trois ours
était bien plus fort sans ce que
proposait maxime généralement cet homme
propose des bons coups il avait tout de
suite vu j'ai tout de suite compris
qu'il y aurait 15 5 et dames g3 web et
le foot c'est pas net pas tout c'est
quand même pas ses bras volant pour les
normes et ses moines est parce que kiev
s'inquiétait de venir en aide si c'etait
un mais bon souper satie quand même
magnifique
d'après la tour qui vient en c2 elle
peut faire mal quand même
voyez ils avaient peur tourbe et un
torrent bessette
logique alors après est ce que les
blancs vraiment quelque chose à faire
mais blanc ouais c'est dur de trouver la
tâche qui est juste envie de faire la
fête mais bon et après donc mensah qui a
réussi sept as envie de te jeter dessus
mais bon car il y en eut cette île
blindes bien quand même état sur les
problèmes de dames pranger de enfin tu
veux pas trop ramener pièce fait à part
les tours qui rentre sur la troisième
est pas la plongée de en ligne de mire
tout le nom je veux pas me 3 non ouais
au tour ces deux autour c3 ou je sais
pas quoi enfin west est quand même je
m'étais juste il se fait harceler la
dame je pense que je vais juste pour ça
il y avait une couille surnomme points 3
non pas spécialement d'accord c'était
jouable
après facebook ne voyez pas en ville
voudrait pour quoi il a peur des bas
mais il est bien là
auo les biens non mais franchement mais
pour l'instant ça se passe bien pour lui
cette bande ou d'eau devrait changer
jarque et c3 qui est aussi sous g5 ou ou
saint chély 7,6 km dont une fois où je
qui a aidé au troisième ou je sais pas
ce qu'ils veulent vendre des changes
mais un moment quand tu te prends un mur
je te dire c'est ce qui fait quand même
très très mal c'est que 6 à 4 1 pour
fabiano après celle là on pourra même
pas dire que fabiano est bien payé non
je devine des gendarmes travaillent
autour f3 ça amy adams et regarde
autour sert même sa force at war 2 sens
là non c'est terrible il se fait
défoncer qui est des six alors hausse
qui va je pense y avoir durant ces 4
c'est ça va pas juste se faire échanger
les dames et tour c3 et bas soit pas
personnellement j'essaie de comprendre
ce qu'ils veulent exactement en même
temps que je sais soir au 6 impasse que
tour ces trois ça faisait une double
attaque
bref c'est un cocker je veux pas prendre
ce point de fourchette
mais il aurait mieux fait avant ça
aurait évité de se prendre ça secret
qu'elle se prend l'option f6 ouais si
c'est pas si grave c'est quand même sur
pareils ça ça peut être chiant à terme
le roi peut être un peu bloqué sur de
mini réseau ouais ouais ok des sommes
que trois non mais tu vas avoir toute
emprise nation à avoir un tour ses cinq
tours en légère par là que ça mais il
pêche en eaux troubles quoi ouais non
mais en blitz et quant aux 20 secondes
chacun s'est pas foutu tout d'un coup tu
fais des trucs quoi petit tour ans et 8
un carré yeux cet échec un tour b 8 face
c'est dommage mais c'est ça ben en fait
le tour des huit aussi qui peut arriver
le choix et 8 qui peut qu'on s'est
trompé et laisse à tu peux être mat très
rapidement là bon on va voir par contre
toujours eu un lien magique et des tours
à chaque match ça fait mal un raté par
duda est vrai mais plus le temps mais
oui bond ou d'ailleurs bon j'espère pour
lui qu'il a changé un truc c'est la
partie d'avant ça allait payer tout son
choix c'est abi qui a changé dans sa vie
qui a changé et on va lui faire dam des
deux grands rock
terrible il avait retourné mais il est
moins fort un bel italien qui est et qui
est vraiment en forme aujourd'hui quand
même femme
mais bon comment lutter contre l'italie
1 compliqué il connaît là tu penses tu
vas bien ou pas il voulait même très
vite
écoute je sais pas je connais pas cette
vente pas d'aussi jouve est en tout cas
à 12h à inverser la partie d'avant entre
le fou sattouf aussi ce machin il est
temps de s'en remettre à l'endroit
donc à temps c'est quoi la critique
sévère car il prend des quatre fous ces
cinq cas également en russie ce fou
prend 3 fou prend 3,2 me ouais c'est pas
bon que ce qui est proche décède tous
assez peu de casse couille jordan 7 kg 7
3 et fuite qui a réduit 5,5 fois
chercher tout ça c'est typique genre et
positions pénibles ah non il n'a pas
fait voilà il est complètement raide je
pense que c'est pas fini fini encore
mais à face à pas du tout là quand tu
commences à prendre la pression comme ça
il a même pas commencé son attaque
c'est vrai je peux avoir sacrifié la
dame ça valait rejouable nom basque on a
vu ouais après tu es ce que les moyens
de ne pas entrer là dedans je sais pas
exactement mais à priori c'était
intéressant
non il est pas bien famille non mais bon
c'est cette nationwar fâche iv c'est
normal pas finir aussi un fin d'études
dans les cases la talqa alexis changer
quatre faces et je suis quand même
d'accord un bureau le pion h 30 bah oui
enfin je crois tu contrôles des cases à
laon h4 il s'est perdu
voilà c'est la catastrophe eu de même
c'est trop la partie en c3 aussi mais
bon tu vas te prendre grand roque en
plus des kf2 qui rôde pas encore je
pense qu'au lieu d'aller taper des g7 ou
quoi mais grand boxeur logique certes
allemand fort du casque à droite puis
lille et tours
du coup
dur bon en fait ils ont le temps ce
thème des parties de cinq minutes donc
là il peut réfléchir
il va trouver sur quel âge hills on voit
carnacois 28-19 et trouver 12 h
d'aravane 3 je dois vu des cabanes de 8
ce qui est plus jeune tout a encore 22
ans et et caruana à 28
quand je vois des livres à tailler un
livre non non il ya un dvd à cheste base
de caruana de bon sur quoi aligner le
taux du louis lopez et beloeil lopez non
ils naviguent ouais il n'a pas pas du
tout paris navigue sans rien dire
qu'enfin ces prix s'est pris pour un
marin quoi c'est terrible
c'est une belle le vin est fort il a
gagné en bas oui contre les lois mais
là-bas dessus il a battu piétonne qui a
qui a quitté d'un trait qui parce qu'on
n'a pas pris pour aller jouer avec les
bras oui jouer avec les bras et a pas de
problème mais bombay est parti je sais
pas depuis les parvenu ces faits ban
du coup il s'est vexé on ne voit plus
faux départ mais bon peu de chance
14 me contacter pour me dire je joue et
ce à la salle avec toi partie tendue
après 1
à pourquoi ils appliqueront europe en
fait j'ai pas mes jambes sont tous
gagnants
maintenant cela revient à eric part j'ai
pas toi je 3 pour revenir sur la colonne
des ça se regarde ou pas la tourache 3,7
père a un truc en d4 ne rappelle jamais
il ya quatre élèves de russie au passage
bon allez tous les coups l'agencé
abandon déjà femmes
en réalité ce rare mais je sais pas ce
qu'il a foutu le feu dans la partie
puisque la fête il ya peut être pas
refaire pareil qu'après douze coups ç'a
l'air d'être en matière est quoi qu'est
ce qui empêchera fourchette en rêve de
rien zitte enfin là c'est juste que tata
l'embarras du choix reste que je me
disais mais à tout reprendre un ici et
c'est la différence avec gros tu
laissais pas c'est sont là je trouvais
en tout cas moi ça va ça va gagner tu
prends aussi ce prix g7 et ce pour trois
familles vivant dans une petite pièce en
fait c'est une tour de plus non de plus
c'est fini
bon c'est la meilleure chance pratique
après ce qu'il a tenté c'est ce que je
pensais aussi pour les blancs mais bon
je n'ai pas forcément dit puisque ça
paiera tout de suite terrible terrible
femmes 2 coûte combien de temps là dans
cette phase à 25 minutes
ok tu penses que c'est assez nom n'est
pas vraiment sûre en tout cas il est
reste voilé je sais pas ce qu'ils
regardent et à tous qui gagne voilà que
des coups gagnants x 3 vous êtes un
autre coup gagnant menace dame prend b2
maths quand même sac ou plus flashy que
juste pendant tout aussi gagnant ouais
mais tout aussi gagnant il ya je résous
qui demanda par d'autres canaux devient
tombons aux échecs et peut- on atteindra
son à démarrer des chèques à 25 points
bas je crois qu'il faut être au moins de
1670 sans vraiment être bon ouais enfin
peut comprendre je sais pas en vrai je
sais pas c'est tellement rare à dire non
mais fix it what objectif pour toi puis
voilà il n'y a pas de tu seras toujours
moins bon que quelqu'un ait les
meilleures fins meilleur que quelqu'un
d'autre on est on sait pas si sûr ça
s'est passé sur sa dépendance au
référentiel quoi ouais ok prend des
cartons un [ __ ] voilà vont chercher
quelque chose de joli bon ça c'était une
partie donnée de fabien c'est le pousser
la première partie en bravant cadeaux
dans ce match de bout en bout d'une
heure voilà qui est il a écouté les
conseils de son compatriote voir ce que
ça donne
cette française fab c'est bien pour les
blancs de hausse quoique c'est bien donc
tu peux jouer avec g3 soi-même kg 300 m
à coups pour sortir le flou en d3 et
rockets h4 se joue à huit tours et les
pions
catherine bloch opinion bien les quatre
choix sur jacques pas forcément faire
une nouvelle fois pas les h4 en vain
mais fabiano qui se met vraiment la
française à fond il a lille a déjà joué
un petit peu ou pas femmes
je crois surtout que mathieu a dit qu'il
a déjà joué en teck fawcett machin a
donc donc je croise rémy mathieu
il fallait peut-être commencer trop fort
d'oudalle attendant les championship
prize est aussi c'est à la 12è ce
fantastique
oui je vais le mettre ko sur cette
partie
après la commencé en jouant bien mais
c'est vrai qu'il se fait un peu remonté
tout et comme il est peut être moins
fort en bullet après on n'en sait rien
si vraiment si moins fort que c'est en
bullet
qu'est ce que vous faites ce jour trop
sur ça c'est intéressant sur vert et
blanc jouent pour avantage de l'espace
en fait l'armée française génère boutoir
de l'attaqué ton centre et l'attaqué un
truc est en béton le problème pour les
blancs en fait tous les sacrifices de
pièces qui peuvent arriver compte
d'options pour péter le centre où tu as
tu t'es pas développé talent ressentent
à la torah je crois qu'on peut être en
vis-à-vis du fou g8 tout ça et souvent
ça joue comme samedi et noir restent
passifs en fait à faire des coups qui
servent à rien les blancs vont se
défoncer tu fais keiji un fou des trois
et un moment tu pars en kg 5 damage 5
matches fermes à terme donc avec les
noirs tu peux pas rester à rien faire il
faut trouver une certaine activité dans
la position à moins un autre
donc c'est intéressant c'était 90 à la
mode
on est au début des années 2000 il y
avait un nombre qui les jeux quelquefois
il avait dû shirov avec par exemple je
crois que j'en retire dijoux audio en
démonstration vous avez joué ça je pense
que les jo de sydney et qu'est ce que je
veux dire d'autre voilà mais en fait les
leurs depuis on trouvait quand même
comment on joue et c'est un peu passé de
passer de mode mais m'écoute pourquoi
pas jouer sa trace en vue que c'est si
mal les autres variantes faut tenter
autre chose près du coup par rapport à
sa cuisse sur le sample kayamb et si
c'est peut-être mal placé à la balade ou
pas pour le bon jack et b4 pas mal ces
[ __ ] ou des droits donc pas pour le
coup qu'on trois mois de telle heure la
tuile bouffe
enfin je pense tu as pourri de lui et
ses envies que les ont bien se cacher
toute attaque laurent moi je le beauf re
sans réfléchir
bref à bien c'est tellement pas son
style de jeu un coup sans réfléchir fait
important qu'il ait quasiment un
carrière non il veut réfléchir ouais
mais la raison en fait un séjour
réflexion les échecs mais il ya ce fou
comme me fait peur j'ai pas lu et ses
environs
parce qu'en plus d'une fois que la
bouffe est acquis et b6 tu enlèves fébé
6 x 6 ça va pas trouver une utilité at
once pièce blanche à cannes donc voila
tout s'est pas attaqué le roi tu enlèves
son choix lui même se sont calmées 4
était bien et bien placé il est stable
il donne du contre je me tiens pour une
fois c'est un vent très logique un bas
niveau il est content de réfléchir il
est content les plus avertis plus il ya
des chances qu'ils jouent au poker en d3
il a l'air heureux si heureux et
réfléchit bien je réfléchis marc besse
le penser non mais je dirais donc soit
sous courbet six fois ci se fout des
sept de leurs huit mais tu pars pars là
bas non mais là ça va pire sacrae droit
tu ferais que cinq doubles au cra tout
sauf à un quatrième veulent venir c'est
cette affaire bessin mais bon déjà se
défendre à cinq avant de faire ça mais
ça peut être une idée ayant tout cas tu
défends tu défendre à cinq ans
bon mais l'attaqué qui s'est encore de
l'autre côté du fleuve saint cloud pour
bloquer
on n'en parle plus actu verrouille moi
je crois je veux pas me permettez je
fais 5 j'ai pu entendre parler de son
passé pas si con tu vois les dames en
bien du coin presse méthode abc studios
blé tour je fais ta petite fille que je
sais ça me fait tellement peur mais
ouais en train de réfléchir la française
je crois que fab il a joué contre eux
quand kasparov saint-louis l'année
dernière non ouais c'est parce qu'il a
joué c'est impossible qu'il a joué un
petit peu mais en longue je me rappelle
pas avoir vu la douleur mais ouais les
cheveux ou pour l'ong je pense que son
berges rapide restera normalement deux
parties un des rêves celle ci dans la
cadence fab
à moins que celle-ci dure vraiment et
qu'on ait deux parties qui dure sinon il
en reste
fajr est celle ci plus de
à moins de deux partis très vite ou très
bon mais ça regarde être dangereux là
quand même pour pour fabi way besoin
qu'un jeu moi j'habitais chez 4 j'ai
l'impression que la pensée qui avait pas
eu toute attaque et qu'il avait le temps
de faire un peu ce qu'ils voulaient mais
il a pris beaucoup de temps parce que
cavaler à 8b 6 cas et c'est cette baisse
5 c'est long quand même c'est très long
moi j'aurais vraiment terroriste
seulement si je pouvais bet5 man en
évidence il l'emprunté contente pour une
tour m 5 g 5
je trouve rire après mais c'est que si
f5 g5 pas le pion à vii ça irait si
celui-ci se fait justice phase 6 mais
avec l'option h si ça a plus du tout
donc près du ferro f2 tour j'ai un
machin tu as maté les noirs et a fait
crisser ses vêtements il a raison de
continuer son plan et son plan est
beaucoup trop long il menace même pas b5
encore s'est complètement plantée là
c'est terrible
fabiano qui craque un peu affables note
le monde en mai g51 club l'un des
tirages prends tu vends sa justice mais
là ça a pas l'air ça ça a pas l'air
d'être bien ce qui nous fait le joueur
américain qui craquent fab
mais là aussi la pression polonaise a
l'air très dur pour toi parce qu'en fait
tu as un polonais contre un fab du sexe
c'est terrible en fait t'es plus pour
les phases peut-être quand même non on
veut que nos portes
c'était une amie qualité de prénoms
georges-louis fab non comme beaucoup le
meilleur gagne le poteau bah oui tu es
gagnants dans les deux cas en fait
exactement soit en quarts de finale tu
auras ton fab et tu as oui bon les
femmes sur les plus forts swahili
polonais donc un fabiano a fallu un
corner de kiev
mais en fait du coup il a deux semaines
face aux italiens à cheveux noirs et les
yeux noirs et le même fait même forme de
visage très basse à ces scellés au
régime qui parle un satie peut rien le
viol qui n'ont pas du tout mais c'est
juste que mon nom c'est libye chef qui
donc serait d'origine polonaise
mais je te confirme que c'est assez pour
le nez quand même si paul à l'aide de
dons enfin c'est très polonais quand
même mais non à d'annoncés très très
très peu neuf et bien plus plus honnêtes
français de nom j'ai l'impression et
très belle génétique caruana on y va
mais la mg5 il sera peut-être pas encore
comme des fous et 8,6 voir venir un peu
coty gigote l'essai de défense mais moi
je suis pour fabiano toute façon dans ce
match je le dis tout de suite on va voir
comment il s'en sort le numéro deux
mondial a quand même fabiano
c'est vrai qu'on a oublié de le rappeler
c'est quand même pas n'importe quoi
c'est clair contre carleton écoute son
match du championnat du monde il n'a pas
perdu en classique 1 finalement non non
non pas du tout il a perdu rapidement
classique qui a eu à égalité il pourrait
être champion du monde un jour fabiano
même si même si avec les candidats il
est mal classé pour lui ce sera vraiment
primordiale un favori tour des candidats
de battre maxime jeu l'enfant l'idée me
les 50% c'est ça il a 50 % bref pas si
longtemps mais un retour la condition
sinequanone d'un retour pour lui aux
candidats c'est une victoire contre
maxime avec les pièces blanches
c'est quoi c'est la première ronde que
sa lumière en vrai il a vu d'autres ça
va réattaquer avec caruana vachier
lagrave caruana blanc et carmona qui
sera au pied du mur ouais bon coûte
évidemment il va tout faire pour gagner
nul c'est pas c'est pas la fin c'est pas
la fin des haricots et ben mouaïa drôme
puis c'est dur a par contre une défaite
c'est fini moi je le vois bien prendre
tous les risques un personne verra bien
il faut avoir l'état de forme peut
traîner normes etc inconnu pas joué
pendant tellement longtemps en fait bas
et qui est motivé comme enfin de tv2
sont tous mais en gros je vai il ya des
joueurs qui ont pris peut-être cette
pose comme une bénédiction parce que
c'est peut-être la première fois enfin
c'est là parfois dans l'histoire ou
d'échec et joueurs peuvent prendre une
pause sans jeu est juste entrés donc en
fait jarre des fois tu dis [ __ ] on les
finales faut que je bosse mais en fait
tu t'appelles tu en penses tu as
toujours refaire s'évertue à tmh un tat
il bon bon bah là en fait un an sans
jouer donc tu peux souffler et refaire
sa re faire des trous dans l'appart wart
un répertoire tout neuf que diable doit
bien jouer des quatre balles at elle
tend maintenant quatre n'ont pas fait ce
qu'il veut j'aimerais voir autre chose
ouais c'est même peut-être la première
fois de leur vie que qui joue pas aux
échecs pendant aussi longtemps un
exactement donc drogué ça peut être vu
comme un côté positif
en fait tous les joueurs ont un temps de
bosser de gommer leurs faiblesses
préparer de nouvelles armes et caetera
etc
par contre aussi dans le lot des joueurs
qui sans échéance ça va les faire chier
de bosser donc ils vont plutôt se
reposer dire ok quand ça reprend je me
veux tu joues pas tu vas et tu es sûr ça
existe aussi ça c'est hyper dur de
tasses train d'uriner viennent de vie à
un boulot à tout ça quand tu sais pas ce
que bauer jeu pendant deux ans pas un
moment qui dit oui bon pas peut-être
autre chose à faire que posséder échec
alors je vais pas jouer il faut demander
pourquoi tu joues quoi ouais non mais
sérieusement c'est vrai c'est pour
l'instant en fait moi je vois pas en
date de sortie du trou est pour
l'instant ok il ya le vaccin a annoncé
90% les russes 92% des races 200 % des
travaux fin de séjour mais à l'heure
actuelle à le vaccin bas qui scanne le
vaccin bas qui cette année est annoncée
à 200% 200 virtuel maroc et le jour il
ya que ça qui marche des chèques pour
roland reprend enfin l'habitude pour
reprendre normalement mais est pour
l'instant écoute c'est compliqué et donc
j'imagine ya des joueurs dans l'eau qui
qui vont moins bosser et donc tu vas
revenir avec des états de forme peut
être fluctuant déjà le fait de porc
jouer ne pas avoir eu à tous concentrés
à subir la pression machin en voiture
joue c'est chaud darbo c'est plus ou
moins
plus ou moins détaché du truc je sais
pas donc c'est hyper dur de jouer au jeu
des pronostics en fait donc difficile de
savoir quels joueurs seront en forme ou
pas donc ça veut dire que d'après toi il
ya une grosse incertitude donc n'importe
qui pourrait même remonter revenir dans
le tournoi éventuellement l'emporter
mais malgré tout qu avec des trucs à 50%
en fait donc qui ça voilà jardine diane
j'y crois pas il est beaucoup trop lent
mais mon rôle les autres pourquoi des
mecs jusqu à tous ceux qui soit 50% il
pourrait potentiellement prête à mon
goût je crois que même permis d'être là
mais les chipmunks irish ne voit pas non
plus mais oui normalement ça devrait se
jouer entre caruana max et et n'est pas
prêt à gré de choc on sait jamais en
fait puisqu'il n'est pas largué du tout
donc pour moi mais bon déjà frotté avec
green party je suis d'accord avec ce que
dit analyser après quand tu as beaucoup
bossé et que tout d'un coup tu t'arrêtes
tu arrêtes de le faire tu peux vivre
tranquille c'est pas forcément facile de
se remettre au boulot pour un toit noir
je veux dire ça va te pas je pense que
c'est trop dur savoir en fait c'est même
pas est ce que le métier sérieux pas
sérieux motivé pas motivés mais c'est
chacun va le vivre à sa manière ouais
donc dû enfin trop dure un peu s'il veut
dire quoi juste impossible a pronostiqué
m et fabiano forcément vu son niveau de
préparation le fait qu'il soit numéro
deux mondial et que et que ce soit un
joueur de premier plan sera évidemment
un candidat sérieux hein
exactement en tout cas c'est rare de
mieux se passer celle là parce que les
noirs
arras est désorganisée me recentre
qatar qui cavaliers à quatre faces art
de faire malin parce que la casse bicici
peut pas contrôler
katz pas se gagner la dame en face à
quatre contre
on commence à le voir ça fait de plus en
plus mal à moi j'avais proposé ça juste
pour satisfaire une fourchette mais en
fait on faisait pareil aussi tu n'as
souffle rauque et valier donc m6 force
c'est probablement bon car elle est à
crête maintenant mais mais l'a pas vue
cavalière 4 il a raté h57 et peut-être
maintenant cavalier à 4 mais le problème
c'est une chance il va falloir partir du
monde tu l'a raté les deux coudes avant
c'est le timing badiate une fusillade a
mis la case au 8 août alors ça
paraissait encore plus sexy mais j'ai
battu * c5 aussi enfin c'est tellement
fort comme tout on a peut-être qui a été
sept noms mais ok salaire juste très
cool c'est juste le timing pas le fait
qu'ils aient pas vues avant ça me fait
penser qu'il va falloir maintenant mais
ça reste ça coûterait bien ça sent qu'il
ya une vraie baisse de régime de karwan
c'est pas le premier coup pas trop
compliqué qui rate un tailleur jupe la
zone à laquelle il avait raté qu'il a
raté quelque chose après c'est que
magnus en match pour sa part un peu
cavalier c5 magnus en match de
championnat du monde il n'a pas été
impérial parce que contre car iachini
fait 6 600 longue et contre caruana ip66
aussi donc en longues en réalité il est
le seul qui l'a battu c'est allende
ouais bon mais je sais pas je radis
enfin il sera favori quand n'importe qui
mais mes favorites reggae mais non il
sera il sera favori c'est sûr mais je
veux dire par là que les mâles
championnat du monde il en a écrasé
aucun nom votre âge on était bien ouais
c'est ça mais les autres non messieurs
dans les carreaux net est extrêmement
bien préparé car yakine
très étonné en fait incroyable après bon
il suffisant car et qui ne s'est pas
n'importe qui on a tendance à l'oublier
quoi mais c'est quand même le mec qui
était le grand maître le plus jeune de
l'histoire
donc niveau de talent il est là et
défend bien et il a un mental d'acier
sur tout juste incroyable ce mental donc
lui la pression mode championnat du
monde au pas et s'en fout pas donc il a
été il était impressionnant car elle
permet à préparer dur à passer dessus ou
quoi mais carole scène tu vois c'est un
peu comme djoko ce que tu t'étais
l'heure pas loin pas loin mais il a
gagné quoi même pas l'emballement
toujours devant et il approche
pragmatique en plus car le sel tard
c'était pas le truc moi qui en tant que
spectateur je trouve ça terrible qui
propose nul la dernière rencontre
caruana je fais du monde là sur ce
marché sur le coffre
il est hyper bien enfin il le sac est
très bien et en fait ça avec d'un côté
pragmatique c'est une telle c'est une
réduction des risques en fait pas tous
actes et bien je sais que probablement
gagné la partie mais tu as peut-être 80%
de chances de gains récents de perdre
chez pas dire des chiffres au hasard est
en fait en gros tu joues un match en
quatre parties rapides contre lui c'est
d'être à 95% de chances de gain en fait
ils positivement de pression il sait
prendre des décisions comme ça sont très
durs a engrossé baude avait détaché ce
qui se passe sur l'échiquier du contexte
en général et de prendre la décision d'
ensemble jusqu'à 10 sion qui va sur
l'échiquier et saïd a bien su le faire
il est confiant ses capacités en rapide
il est confiant tout court 1 mais il
sait que généralement des partages de
quoi il perd pas bon il est vrai une
fois compte ding en quinze ans qu'on va
y renvoie donc il a ce côté là il a
l'habitude des matches il a à son actif
deux préparateurs il a il a ses
habitudes
donc je tout fait que évidemment impulsa
il est juste il fut très fort tout court
en fait un même sans tous ces trucs là
donc il sera favori mais bon favori ce
n'était pas que tu gagnais coup sûr il
alors à ne pas être en forme
l'adversaire droite dans la forme de sa
vie de tous vers un point faible de
trouver quelque chose aussi quoi et puis
ça peut aussi tourner un peu comme dans
un match pour ceux qui peuvent sans
rappeler le match crâne mika nand gamiq
était plus ou moins favori il s'est fait
défoncer avec les blancs va quant à
l'âge il était l assister sur les merola
ouais ouais
mauvais choix d'ouverture et du coup tu
sais tu peux te retrouver là dessus tu
prends tu t'attends à entrer dans une
ouverture car le salon ces qui change
beaucoup tu rechange même avec les
blancs genre vu une deuxième fois je te
refais planté quelque part et était à 2
0 et ribéry mais surtout nous partirons
pas tant sa 13e défaite c'est chaud de
ce charmant bébé
donc c'est c'est compliqué ça peut aller
très vite aux échecs et et on peut on
peut on peut perdre pied sur un ou deux
mauvais choix et c'est fini d'ailleurs
il n'était pas loin caruana dans la
suisse nicole fils n'est pas loin
d'avoir un avantage à wemmel vaches avec
les ordis donner plus de 6
pam il ya eu deux chances qu'il aura
fait du sessad petrov le une pièce de
plus ok mais ça a été vraiment dur
ah ouais il perdure mais en fait c'est
une vraie chance oui oui c'est une vraie
chance et et l'autre lâché snica-fo la
première où il a fait un coup de hache 3
à un moment un peu mou et d'arrachages
ouais ouais ça je veux ça aussi mais à
part lundi que près en gagnant cette
partie car ça n'allait se réagir et
peut-être qu'ils aient dit quand même
quand on sait pas mais c'était karma
notre histoire oui oui très clairement
très clairement donc ce match était pas
loin et le match
karlsson cardiaque inkari qui ne mène
d'un point il ya cette fameuse partie ou
caruana les noirs et y aura qu'une
répétition pas simples avait trouvé mais
la répétition jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve
trop bas il y fait nul cette partie je
crois que c'est fini direct sur la
dernière il a les blancs et ils auraient
fait nul oui non mais tu vas falgère la
première chez ski club du match pas la
première partie à la première partie oui
magnuson gagnant à la hcg 5 et tout ça
mais un match par match championnats du
monde quand les deux façons on finissait
à 6 partout c'est que ces cas idéaux que
des occasions manquées de part et
d'autre ouais et l'a d'ailleurs c'est
vrai que si magnus gagne la première
partie pareil c'est peut-être match et
je finis oui il est complètement gagnant
gestion qui se fait retourner été
complètement gagnant car voilà en
parlant de ça et là il est complètement
fou tu gagnes et tu recules moi aussi
fait déjà tant il est vrai que j'étais
parti sur une discussion parce que on
avait l'impression que faites vous ici
personne là c'était 4 4 en fait c'est 4
4 marc complètement contre le cours du
match passé impressionnant c'est comme
une qualité de moi et des pions avant
pions vont trop vite on voit quand même
voir un peu sa pointe de vitesse
alors s'il va rester une partie derrière
ou pas à tanger le chrono officiel pour
y restaurer une partie derrière il peut
se retrouver derrière à posto section de
jeudi mais bah écoute c'est incroyable
ça qu'après trois parties qui est bien
parti vale la rater le cavalier à
carhaix ce prix là il a raté pas mal de
choses j'ai l'impression que là tout va
il est rentré dans son match et en plus
les cadences vont accélérer
je pense duda maintenant énorme favori
du match et moralement le truc c'est que
le bullet le favorise donc on met ça
tourne déjà à quatre et demi quatre et
demi c'est plutôt en sa faveur
et en plus ça le scénario de match en sa
faveur exact j'ai pas de ces gens sans
que ce sera un match de tennis en cinq
sets tu sais qu'au 5e tu es plus fort
physiquement et l'autre il mène 1 set 0
5 2 service à suivre étude est vrai que
tu dis est vrai que tu lui prend le
deuxième set bon sachant jean claude tu
fais mal quoi une éthique à rien une
cette partie sur huit effet 4 4 en 5 + 1
ça promet pour les bullet ouais c'est un
peu ça madame d2 j'ai pas trop aimé rv
plus haute c'est chiant ce le plus joué
le caillou de facilement si elle
s'éprend décès prend des coups mais qu'a
donc donc je n'ai pas à dire à faire
bref de quoi ce bordel ou a3 d'abord web
à trois noms et à 5
ok c'est malheur résoudre le truc de
concert salsa mais le cheval en d4
paraissent pas si cons on va voir à mon
avis un pas l'un il est beaucoup plus
importante pour fabiano que pour 12 à
salah je pense fabiano c'est important
de casser l'hémorragie ici et de gagner
une partie de ces de reprendre le lis tu
vois de partir en pause en mode ok c'est
la pause mais je mène d'un point quoi
j'ai raté les occasions je suis un peu
une verte
laissez-vous de se dire ça quand tu pars
en faudrait bon j'ai raté des occasions
et un peu une merde mais maintenant ça
va je
j'ai tellement dominé jeu quand même de
voir malgré tout très beau livre une
interview comme ça fabien de france et
quoi vous est cher la tête du gars en
face je pense il d'état ce nom faut
vraiment faire le buzz raoui que
proposer ça comme je suis j'ai c'est
exceptionnel su élever sa oui tu qu'il
faut ça c'est à l'exceptionnelle la
création vous étiez un peu une merde à
ce moment de fifa ça donne tellement
envie de faire le stream en anglais pour
voir pourrir le truc qu à la fin poser
les questions qui vous est question à 2
orange
ouais je te dire des questions seraient
pas les mêmes à ce serait pas
fantastique match racing tour avalisée
alors fabiano ayew mistletoe fauqué
jones industrial swan a eu une élite
player style est-il défonce nous
explique d'où dyoula cela six organs au
unity mines quarterfinals gunn white
mountain la wii why do you play qui lui
fait très très mal quoi pourquoi tu
joues en quarts moi je suis à 3 tempo là
non pas toi même bien réfléchir vote
annoncés tout temps il s'est agi sous le
nom mais en plus si tu vas te font bien
c'est bien son prix baisser mais j'aime
bien réglant la mire de la tour certains
devront le faire
bon ok je pas cet échange tu finis ouais
mais enfin j'aurai 40 pour la finale et
faire ça pour les risques avant
toujours vous prendra trois qui peuvent
rodez pas vraiment y arriver à le faire
c'est dur mais j'ai une idée avec les
bleus en fait avec les noirs je sais pas
comment il peut gagner
alors tu peux pas la cij à la haye thing
fire et karkwa rioux ch that you were
better than your open d'after d'histoire
il faut surtout pas y voir si riche ou
alors ils y cherchent non mais là j'aime
bien les blancs axa partir c'est partout
c'est beau quand le match il a tourné
sur deux conneries de caruana à la
partie le 4 0 qui doit faire le 3 0 qui
doit faire 4-0 il fait 3 ouais bah après
refait 4-1 il gagne bien puis donne une
partie vraiment complètement avec les
blancs ça fait 4 2 elle refait une
partie de noir de merde avec les noirs
et puis re raté un truc à lui nommé cbc
m'enfin doodle depuis j'ai switché
l'ouverture l'arrêt des 20 qu'il y eu
deux le fait beaucoup plus chaud avec
ben franchement je pense que 6,2 caruana
c'est juste le score logique ici les
melkites réseau audois vers tours très
facile abbas était fait
elle était faite avec toi la vidéo quand
même on en a marre
bon bah sinon le répertoire était raté 1
il rêvait il y aura des trous partout où
il va les bétons tu n'as pas parler de
deux des quatre dans ta vidéo no 4 des 5
des 4 tu n'en a pas parlé
du coup ça va parler de la transposition
dans l'appât 9
ce serait beau que tu as répertoire tu
leur fais là panov à fontana l'isaf ont
quoi ils regardent débutants et vidéo de
huit heures dans ta gueule
jeanne d'arc
non mais c'est bien ce scandinave pour
éviter des attentats deux bonnes heures
trente habituelles entre 4,5 et skf
c'est pas mal parce que tu es une
structure à savoir c'est assez simple de
comprendre ici et tu sais où le maître
des pièces tu te fais pas ta qui
rapidement va pas de match réd 7 a pas
de trucs
voilà n'est pas de cacher mais je pense
qu'ensemble on va faire une à la petrov
en soi une petite petrov ensemble en
tête en trois vidéos je sais pas comment
on fera
trop facile mais seulement je sais pas
il ya une mode là j'ai pas mal des rêves
les mecs débutant leur joue là petrov ou
sur qui est pro synchro qui sait si
c'est là il ya une mode s'avère une
vidéo youtube de rosen j'étais très
énervé quand
avec sky arc en fait quand il a commencé
parce qu'en fait je sens au zen tard aux
années gotham qui font des vidéos pour
les débutants répertoire qui te
recommande alors là c'est terrible à
dire je vous la pire que c'est très bien
au pire castaing diane ont déjà été bien
alors sur des 4ème et tu peux le faire
sur e4 aussi donc c'est bien c'est le
même système
ouais et que des gants vie de merde et
viennoise fin que des trucs que tu dois
pas faire quand les débutants en fait
fallavier noël est très content ça
t'apprend à faire f 4 en début de partie
facile mais ça c'est attention c'est les
deux chaînes qui regardent ces les mieux
recommandé c'est ce que les gens
recommande mais du coup ils se
retrouvent à de se faire des gants b-sat
ford fin ils te font que de la merde et
les gens du coup ils suivent pas ce que
c'est les vidéos qui sont recommandées
par youtube par l'allemande et c'est
très mauvais pour démarrer mon coach
gameloft mais ça fait déclic
non mais c'est terrible en fait pas mort
je ne dis pas que c'est pour les
débutants et dit que c'est fun jeu enfin
jean pascal fun quoi en fait tu as
toujours le même piège mais je veux à 2
2 personnes à qui j'ai fait des cours
qui ont fait la même truc ça marrant ils
ont fait bouger ça que son pays qu'après
quatre là avec eux font preuve de machin
mais va-t-elle seule pièce de la vente
quasiment tous les quais g4 à mach 4 mai
oui après 5 coûte juste un mois devant
ses fans mais la laïcité est une petite
sur une feuille pour démarrer d'abord
pourquoi pas non mais pour la peine la
petrov c'est pas mal on avait parlé un
peu de la carro cannes ou quoi mais en
fait que les gens retrouvent leur style
est de type de vision qui leur vendent
en gros des buts a pas ni la culture ni
le temps pour étudier cinquante mille
trucs trop compliqué tant faut rester
cohérent avec un jarret position qui se
ressemblent savoir où mettre les pièces
pas se prendre deux pièges et se faire
défoncer et puis tout va bien bonjour et
puis petit à petit vous allez progresser
et puis complexifierait tout ça et ça va
aller mais bon ben il va perdre et voilà
c'est tout ce que j'ai ici c'est un
match gagné la partie pédagogique de la
journée pédagogique
la baby sitter complètement différent ah
oui non mais vraiment en fait
mahmoudi ce que le chat ça parle pas
vraiment des partis ça va pas en
redéfinir y insérant différentes déjà
s'appelle même nom c'est encore
différent du just chatting rapport
différent là tu fais des partis en même
temps du cha cha ting tings et jazzy
partie pédagogique c'est que pédagogie
est parti avec spectateurs c'est entre
les deux un peu les deux c'est just
pédagogie peut-être même et 5
en fait je c'est bizarre le score est
pas gros et tout mais je crois que la
physionomie du match fait tellement mal
web on n'est pas largués mais oui oui ça
prend une mauvaise tournure la pose de
lui faire du bien et va réfléchir parce
que la française il prend un peu l'eau
dans cette branche là justement que les
différentes étapes a le même centre
ouverte a pas les mêmes trucs
enfin il est pareil d'affaires sont des
quatre et que fo bessette qui joue là
par exemple donc ça change un peu tout
ça et est donc fort kiwi puisse réagir
avec compliqué est ce que je fais une
petite pause me chercher un petit truc à
boire il m'a dit je reviens dans cinq
minutes plus ou moins pas par magie
tranquillement qu'il allait ensuite
quand on tend merci on n'entend pas ton
temps que l'écossaise et la lapine par
manque de temps et préparer je m'en sors
bien à 6 ans et lola ben voilà six ans à
l'eau c'est bien
600 lots c'est pas mal hein façon les
fautes elles se font ailleurs vous avez
très en forme visiblement et il a la
forme il joue bien en milieu de jeu il a
raté son début de match mais le truc
c'est que fabiano au lieu de de fer ont
fait du score il a commencé à craquer
donc finalement finalement ça tourne
bien pour le joueur polonais qui fait
enfler ont fait le score
marc comment ça on va voir comment ça
continue un tas le contemporain libye
qui souffrent non qui souffrent pas au
contraire eux qui mènent ces monts
contemporain qui souffrent va bien sûr
que compte la sicilienne alors hello je
débutais les échecs qui hier j'ai appris
les déplacements vous pensez que je dois
faire quoi maintenant comment je
m'améliore veux tu peux aller voir ma
chaîne youtube il ya quelqu'un que tu
vas te mettre le lien est allé partie
pédagogique était une petite playlist
pour débuter qui est sympa ça peut à mon
avis bien t'aider
talleu vlad boutoille voilà qui t'a
répondu que le point d'exclamation
débutants et donc duda qui qui fait mal
ben non je passais mon contemporain et
j'ai toujours je la vente dans ta vidéo
sur escaut et 8500 tu pourrais sortir en
iso sur la perte de 800 bus dont tu
demandes toujours plein de trucs
commente oddo said ça peut à force
mérite un badaud si un fai comme
attention ce que tu demandes des scream
dans des vidéos et tout était assez de
demande en quoi un moment donné ça
pourrait partir en bane je te cache pas
n'empêche hennebelle avait annoncé
caruana gagnant au début 1/3 aux doses
où la victoire de 4-1 à la fin pour
l'instant je trouve sa propre
oui sauf que ces doux dingues qui va
gagner un kevin est ce que tu as prévu
de faire une idée d'ouverture contre
quatre agents est sorti une ce matin du
coup franc les tchèques
lorsque la peau est née avec les blancs
quand et 1200 à 1400 heureux c'est
jouable 1 j'ai fait ma première partie
en lit j'ai gagné grâce à ton ouverture
écossaise où est-ce efficace
je viens de tester un prêt à partie avec
ta variant de la signature la partie
facile pour les noirs qui se traduit par
une victoire et ben voilà c'est ça qu'il
faut mettre en commentaire les gars un
tour est prévue bientôt aballah saleh
durant ce moment et que coville qui est
ce que tu pourrais continuer à faire dès
ce trimestre et pis j'aime bien merci de
chasse en est maintenant aux commandes
aux socialistes ce qui est trés qui est
très demandant dans le tchat
je veux c'est un jour tu sur ce ring col
bat rue j'en ai déjà joués d'école
gluant comme système mairesse est pas là
combien de vue la vidéo elle est déjà
13200 vue elle est sortie ce matin c'est
terrible il ya beaucoup de gens qui la
regardent ya khouya 915 poussent vers le
haut il ya sept gens qui n'ont pas aimé
la vidéo quand même ils ont dû se dire
non on a des débutants c'est de la merde
c'est le cas je suis un exercice de
l'a26 et de réfléchir sur une position
d'une partie de gm une astuce sont pas
choisir au hasard et avoir une position
intéressante ah non lui te prends toutes
les toute la partie avec sa fiche
tu réfléchis au coup par coup ah oui tu
vas te présenter tu arrêtes la position
14e coup tu vas faire ton et une pendule
tu vas passer trois heures dessus tu vas
être heureux j'ai découvert taschen
franchement avec clean
les plans de jeu sont claires pour les
débutants c'est vraiment bien et ça n'a
envie de s'investir ben écoute c'est
parfait un plat je vous retourne ok ok
ok on est en train de dire le chat on
est pas mal de nouveau et beaucoup de
gens qui sont de nouveau trop bien ta
vidéo sur une rature contre 4,3 win sur
trois pour le moment rien mais c'est
vrai que sans cette ouverture là pour
les gens qui sont entre 600 et 1200
c'est vraiment efficace
abbas est super bon ça permet de ne pas
apprendre et il n'y a pas vraiment de
pièges en fait tu gagnes pas sur des
pièges avec cette ouverture
tu gagnes c'est comme jouer aux échecs
voilà c'est ça mais c'est un peu
l'essentiel fait justifie ce que je veux
dire
c'est dommage en fait les joueurs que le
gagner avec des maths du berger je
prends un exemple connu c'est quand on
sort le chou la dame est en fait c'est
pas vraiment haguenau et chaque ce que
tu fais un piège qu'on ne connaît pas
que je veux quatre coups tu vas gagner
il n'y a pas de partie et arrière et
voilà donc en fait un jour tu vas
arriver à je compte des jambes a juste
on salue le voit c'est fait pour être
sûrs qu'ils ont appris ça me paraît donc
tu vas pas gagner comme ça et tu seras
pas faire donc autant lancer la partie
comme on peut et puis puisse améliorer
dans le fond de jeu tout ça voilà c'est
un peu ça l'idée de ce répertoire en
photo c'est vraiment l'idée c'est de ses
larmes heures un truc et ne pas gagner
sur des pièces que je dis toujours quand
j'ai des gens qui débutent n'apprenez
pas à gagner sur des pièges vous ne
prenez rien en fait
non tu apprends un pillage en fait c'est
tout mais tu apprends pas bien ou à
jouer toujours aux échelles ouais ça
c'est vraiment important
cgl tenir du fait que dès sa crise de
fourrage ça de vue keïta master class
sur le faux prince mais ça ça marche pas
tous non détrompe-toi 95 % de réussite
parfaite salut qu'à qui peut restituer
le resituer le match ce n'est pas
actualisée sur trois comme ça un
huitième de finale comme écrite premier
tour premier tour pas une demi-finale
spanyi final c'est un premier match on
écoute un sa vie bon je vraiment une
interview piquante des joueurs entre les
rendre meilleurs et plein de truc fun à
faire pour pour rendre ces compétitions
un peu plus excitante mais bon cela ait
pas de calendrier pour la suite après à
nant banon on sait aujourd'hui on sait
que ça joue demain après on sait pas
parce que c'est dommage sans plus si la
ta vraiment une année que je peux faire
un clin d'oeil à la vancelle apparemment
de tourner avec elle mais là ya pas de
toi
mais bon j'imagine mais je sais bien que
d'habitude ça détourne a dream et les
anciens y'a que ça me va bien que cent
mille dollars de prix fall parce que dû
me bloquer une date pour prendre 25
mille euros + tout ce que tu gagnes non
mais tu ne peux pas non je ne peux pas
savoir c'est normal tout le monde est
comme ça les gens quand ils ont bossé le
matin est ce que tu peux venir bosser ce
matin je ne sais pas je te dirai demain
enfin on vise tous comme ça la société
marche comme ça je ne te réponds pas si
j'en lundi matin je ne te dis pas je
s'avérer dimanche à 22h30 pour qu'ils
sachent pour être bien sûr comelade mais
là il faudra vendre ses fantastiques
mais c'était ben tu veux où je donne des
cours ou est-ce que j'en trouve en fait
sur internet beaucoup ces temps ci
sinon j'aurais pu être en réel en temps
normal mais là pas trop la période mais
beaucoup ont fait tout ça n'en fait pas
tous tous ceux qui donnent des cours en
ce moment c'est comme ça qu'est ce qui
m'a sorti de là de faire un truc et pour
le truc de mardi quand même pour être
bien sûr je dois l'appeler mardi matin
pour un poids être bien sûr quand même
pas bien sûr bassett sokode écouter son
avis sur le film rien et ça va être
interdite mais bon bah c'est mardi soir
s'est bloqué mais quand même mardi matin
pour être bien sûr on va trouver un truc
bail
sinon c'est pas bien sûr mais mais du
coup c'est marrant qua non mais ça va
être marrant son avis mais je pense
qu'il est plutôt positif un jeu sans ben
non mais en fait c'est plutôt positives
dans l'ensemble pour les échecs ce qui
se passe en tout cas d'exception après
jean pattes alors un prêt cornetto quoi
c'est je pense à puce plus haut non
joueurs que joueur mais beaucoup de
temps bien enfin si ça attire du public
que ça fait une bonne pub et tout ça
maintenant il fait dans l'autre sens de
suite d'échecs est toutefois sa pièce
d'eau joueurs là au moins c'est fait
pour ça pèse bon joueur c'est mieux mais
moi je verse à mehdi plus j'ai pas
compris pourquoi ces 107 si bien pas
pourquoi les gens sont tellement
admiratif du truc que tu as une série je
prends m six sur dix ont un truc comme
ça si selmi pas un truc correct et
regarde aller mais pas non plus waouh il
ya des trucs qui vont très bien d'autres
un peu moins procédure en pareil on aime
on aime poste comme les films mais mais
là en fait je vois tellement tellement
d'avis unanime comme quoi c'est
fantastique je viens de voir un article
sur france inter je vois je vois des
gens sur twitter de partout de toutes
horizons c'est assez incroyable en fait
j'ai rarement vu un truc tu vois qu'il
était aussi utile autant unanimement
unanimité pas voilà c'est incroyable
bref la dgre aux cinéphiles son ex
copine elle travaille dans le milieu du
cinéma et tout donc il peut avoir un
avis père intéressant et il a beaucoup
fait de recherche donc merci midi qui
pensent que pour les mondiaux il ya
beaucoup plus de choses en priant
appréhender donc ouais de truc le plus
de matière que les joueurs rsa et
découvre un univers qui va la vie des
points d'univers et puis les échecs
times d'un côté fascination évidemment
c'est un jeu qui représente
l'intelligence et ses terrains et donc
tu dis ouais je ferai comprendre c'est
trop compliqué pour moi et qu'en fait tu
comprends un peu tu prends je te vois de
la carrière je peux plus ou moins
comprendre mais en gros moi j'ai envie
de dire 60 une série qui parle pas
d'échec je reprends mon parent garde
alors que là j'ai l'impression que les
gens auraient aimé que ce soit n'importe
quoi soit une championne de backgammon
sera bien marché aussi j'étais en fait
les gens ont pensé chaque égale smart
n'est pas du tout et non mais c'est vrai
que c'est un autre truc les gens pensent
tout est intelligent pour bien jouer aux
échecs ce n'est pas du tout vrai ça me
rappelle une phrase que je disais sur je
raconte souvent ce truc il ya un forum
de poker très connus twoplustwo là je
faisais pas je sais pas aux échecs n'a
pas l'équivalent mais ce serait un peu
l'endroit où tous les joueurs de poker
un peu bon discuter un forum assez
austère en termes de mise en page mais
c'est un peu là que tous les pros se
retrouve en fait j'aime bien un jour ce
qu'a écrit un procès qui est un gars qui
dit voilà je gagne 4 5000 euros poker
machin je suis assez bon
enfin bon j'ai passé assez loin en fait
son poste et le mec lui répond à la fin
prêt pour un truc mec assez connus en
plus il répond un truc très salée visite
était si intelligent que ça pour geri 4
5000 euros poker tu ferais quelque chose
d'autre de ta vie sic quittera mort
c'est beaucoup plus way est en fait j'ai
aimé la phrase dans le sens ok t'es fort
au poker tu fais le malin c'était fort
au poker blablabla mais en fait je gagne
que 4000 $ par mois en fait j'ai pas
feinte à plein de gens beaucoup plus
intelligent que toi en fait il ya une
beaucoup plus sévère un tu vois ce que
je veux dire il avait défoncé quoi et
avec qui est dégoûté après on s'était
passé non non je vais pas vous rappelle
plus de la chute mais juste c'est la
phrase qu'il avait marqué en fait ce que
je me suis en fait c'est beaucoup plus
mart une punchline ce qu'il a mis ces
graines tu fais le malin parce que tu
calcules vie tu es bon en arithmétique
fait vite et trucs ou quoi mais en fait
pas t'es pas si bon poker déjà et puis
et puis te passer intelligent si
longtemps réunissant 100 chez pas quoi
en nucléaire jusqu'à un ingénieur
nucléaire ou je sais pas quoi ou fin
j'en sais rien ce que tu ferais mais je
vous c'était marrant comme phrase et
j'ai trouvé je trouve que ça ça peut
aussi se mettre aux échecs
georges en bourse était très intelligent
mais t'es sûrement très intelligent
situe non en fait les échecs
je pense à des notes plupart des des
bourgeois afin de joueurs allaient wade
ils ont des capacités cognitives mais
c'est pas breton tu vas où on dit avoir
un bon cuit ça montre juste que tu es
bon tu as des bonnes capacités pour
répondre à un test de qi oui voilà ça
directement aux échecs ça montre que tu
es bon pour bien jouer aux échecs mais
pas plus en fait
non non mais en fait en général assez
bon dans pas mal de jeux sont les
bronzés chaque maison bah si tu prends
la peine de piété à ces méta côté
compétiteur d'un côté et aime bien
essayer de comprendre comment ça marche
mais bon ça n'a pas de toit avec
quelqu'un rien ou quoi
c'est une certaine intelligence mais à
toute forme d'intelligence
c'est une forme d'intelligence il
fallait être intelligent tout court
ouais c'est ça c'est exactement ça d'où
la punchline gars du poker en fait parce
que le dessous des trolls marne ce qui
était bon poker et du coup il feinte ok
t'es juste bon poker en fait c'est tout
et c'est pas toujours évident qu'il
transfère transfert sans cesse d'aider
des compétences ouais non mais c'est
intéressant fait comme truc c'est pour
ça c'est avec les gens ça les fascine et
enceintes et les échecs représente
l'intelligence alors qu'en réalité ça
représente une forme d'intelligence
voilà c'est ça donc près de voir des
joueurs qui jouent aux échecs sont très
intelligents doute pas du tout d'où
souffle très cultivé d'autres patent
enfin peu importe ça se sache pas de
tout quand je regarde les reports les
petites émissions d'y penser sur les
gens qui ont changé le monde de la
physique des mathématiques etc
c'est beaucoup plus impressionnant que
kasparov ou fischer ou que ce sont en
fait c'est pas juste patiné on fait ça a
changé le cours de l'humanité mais pour
de vrai que non mais c'est un peu comme
le truc entre einstein est hélas très
bien rester mais sans voix c'est une
histoire vraie que vous en faites mais
non mme après fou c'est bien deux c'est
bien de se passionner points deux fois
critiqué voit très bien les skieurs il
était champion du monde bravo non c'est
vrai que c'est sûr mais c'est vrai que
bombes einstein
ok bon juste pour pas de la position
passe pas trop mal pour fab il faudra
conclure jusqu'à et des quatre noms à
quai à 5 savoir-faire aussi acquis et
éducatives et peut-être fou ces cinq du
coût élevé et l'aesc n3 faire nous c'est
quoi cette histoire
bah je sais pas étonnant mais en gros
que einstein disait ce car c'est un peu
coincé tout mon temps et mon énergie
pour ce jeu alors qu'il ya quelque chose
à faire dans ma vie mais en même temps
il
j'ai pu commencer mais oui c'est le
temps reste est si intelligent que c'est
dommage de perdre autant de temps pour
que pour une chose si je suis trois jeux
que j'ai plus attendre en fin vous tapez
sur bâbord est la mienne le forgeur
d'échecs et de la sq est un homme doté
d'un cerveau quel site extraordinaire
qu'il gâche inutilement devrait un
échiquier avait s'en servir des forces
importantes cessions fictives
comme si la sq arrêté était heureux
comme ça et il fait ce qu'il veut mais
je la vis et c'est juste marrant que
dans le dans la croyance collective en
fait être fort aux échecs veut forcément
dire être intelligent alors que ça peut
vouloir le dire comme pas cech s'est
ouvert et on n'y a pas de coup je dirais
tu peux être intelligent ou pas tu peux
faire plein de choses
c'est pas suffisant soit pour tirer des
conclusions non du coup on en conclut
quoi bon vu qu'on conclut pas bah oui
c'est ça qui est terrible en fait c'est
que la conclusion du plus c'est qu'il en
a pas ça assez concluant g6 a l'air fort
tout t phones station c'est avec le roi
bloqué au centre c'est quand même un
problème ou 7 il a tenté petit rock ce
thème des 5 un truc ou actes auraient
fin c'était même genre d'idée en fait
pourquoi tu racontes
mais bon c'est pas des fois ça se voit
que c'est écrasant wigan à une minute
c'est beaucoup mais elle a mené cinq là
n'ont juste pas tous les coups sont bien
c'est sûr enfin je crois que tu veux pas
vraiment faire d'erreur imagine tu fais
un missclick j'en ai un qui m'a fait ça
avant-hier robson mais m'attend de hilla
missclick j'ai pris ça la faisait lui je
suis venu j'ai une âme de plus oui mais
c'est un truc aussi con que d'amuser tu
vénères 17 tient tant par 17 des
perdants j'ai pensé à qui et bessette
monsieur comme votre côté sympa monsieur
bien là ça change plus de françaises
poussent le pion de gaz devient sérieux
et une petite italienne jus qu'au piano
c'est assez théorique mais je pense que
c'est un bon choix de fabiano bas à la
française ça qu'on savait plus trop
allez donc il reste bon de changer faut
savoir way des dessous de changer un peu
d'ouverture par ci par là
dans un match pareil est pas pas se
faire enfoncer sur l'arc etc souvent ils
changeaient d'ouverture entre les
séquences sont à l'impression qu'ils ont
décidé avant je joue sajou ou sajoo ça
jamais compris pourquoi pourquoi tu
change pas un peu à chaque partie fatwa
toi tu dis pas bons à cinq plus un jour
f1 au lieu de faire c'est un peu de
cette a décidé française de 5 par
exemple tu fais une française à eux cinq
une française du 5 mai t'as pas mal de
joueurs comme fabiano qui vont jouer que
les françaises en 5 plus simple qui a
appris que des eaux 53 plus un ouais
ouais je sais pas en fait ouais c'est
vrai qu'on ne sait pas gérer tout ça
juste remarquer que ça arrive assez
souvent je comprends pas vraiment la
raison et je sais pas peut-être les plus
simples de sur un fond de jeu qui tiens
tu perds pas ton énergie pense et je
sais pas en fait tu as eue de faire des
réactions émotives aussi peut-être mais
avec quatre super super inadaptabilité
ou quelque chose puisque tu peux sentir
près de sept tours malte a pas besoin
d'insister en fait les mister kahn qui
tend un peu pas de chance ça hilarant et
des cas qui assaillent ramener les
fameux kaki pomme est moins bon ils sont
fatalement défoncer sur la chaîne et kia
qui promet de doubler sekkaki le pauvre
ça lui prend des cayes mais pour qu'il
soit monté ce que l'équipe sommes en
face à balma qui a expliqué parce que
quand même il est bien renseigné bien
sur le sujet parce qu'ils se conservent
beaucoup mieux mais ça que les autres
quand ils sont mûrs faut les manger tu
peux pas attendre un peu mais bon tant
pis y'a pas de tu prendras le bon kaki
au bon moment quoi donc acquis comme ça
frère avec un cac qui est une terrible
sacrifice un prêt bei c'est un truc
bizarre sur la langue un peu rappeuse
après alors il sont puis séduire
convaincre des mois je veux le couple
que qui gicle dans la bouche qu'ils
soient qu'ils souhaitent ou quoi et donc
les 5 + 1 3 + 1 1 plus 1 c'est les
cadences alors le 5 1 c'est le temps
qu'ont au début de la partie et le plus
c'est le nombre de secondes qu'on
obtient après chaque coup joué là par
exemple avec le plus après chaque coup
ils vont récupérer une seconde
voilà ce qu'ils évitent en général de
perdre à cause de la pendule
même si une seconde s'est pas beaucoup
en fait mais ça va permettre jouer un
coup à chaque fois ok à ça qui va faire
fou g4 si l'info à part verra deux bons
c'est intéressant le plan d'eau fabiano
le caillage sept 2006 tout ça était de
2-2 ne l'agressé
voilà peut-être pas un roc était ici
c'est en voie non à ce que tu as en mai
position pas mal les blancs bien pris le
centre mais bon du coup et noir je suis
arrivé à contourner mais les pièces
autour on sait que les blancs tape pas
hyper envie de faire des points 5 passes
que mal fou à 7 milliards vite vers f2
donc c'est toujours fait tu aimes bien
alors demandé 4 - tu du coup le bac on
va dire qu'on s'en fout on peut grâce à
trouver quand tu te places du pied d'un
petit four b2 un petit os x 3 probable
voilà pour le goût d'une aide vraiment
des points vous faudra faire tourner 8
j'imagine ou tour j'ai pas trop envie de
jouer mais bon moi je préférerais plutôt
les blancs en fait je sais pas
exactement quand l'honneur de jouer mais
mais bon rien fait c'est compliqué comme
position je ne savais pas si je me
sentirais pas si mal acquis et noir tu
vois oh non je ne suis pas si mal mais
ça passe contrôle du centre après justin
mention des poubelles avec les marchés
l'impression que tout est mieux que ma
scandinave pour avant fait qu'il n'ait
que à +0 50 avec les blancs je suis
quand même très bien sortie de
l'ouverture dakar va devoir faire ses
cinq ans avec les normes malheureusement
et ouais mais du coup on n'a pas envie
mais bon probablement tapant avec les
blancs façon plus
bah oui à tapas en ville tu vas devoir
faire ses cinq étaient un peu mal à
trouver six du vous qui est moche caisse
des cinq qui est moche le kenya 5 qui
hors jeu problème hausse un problème sur
les problèmes aux deux chez problème à
cela une famille qui réfléchit trop quoi
toi sont ces 5 tu dois jouer toujours un
peu plus vite la c il a tellement peu de
temps ouais voilà blanche qualifié de
tour des seins et tour des 5 si tu peux
tu peux pas tenté juste de tout liquider
c'est de tenir la finale pour av
mais bon qui est des deux tf1 qui les
trois aussi c'est une bonne idée je
pense
il n'a pas joué il a fait flouer 2
pouces et 7
mais pourquoi pas c'est à dire mettre le
fond c'est vrai dans mes pouces et 3
offre un bon c'est mieux pour les blancs
mais rien n'y fait les deux le plan de
fab complètement plan de falla ouais bon
après c'est le plein tout le monde que
j'avais bien dans ce genre de position
mais il est logique
la différence entre les deux cavaliers
de ces bêtes de battre son dessin tous
répondent des silhouettes de parapher
dame si ça s'était très mal un tour qui
ont plus c'est sur un troisième jeu que
l'on en croit tous les dangers trois
mois trop cher je pense que très bien là
bas tu veux que tous terrible à voir ou
à revoir ci conclut militaire bien
maintenant il ya une nouvelle fois ya
tout qui va bien pour les bouts sayah
leurs fouilles à l'éco l'ania tous allés
tour à deux tours à 8,1 de façon tabal
choix oublie que t'as aucune chance font
un montant dû on sait jamais mais je
joue tel impôt en fait non mais c'est
gagnant mais c'est pas a fait tant de
temps qui a pas de matériel en plus dans
ces parties l'acceptent
temps tu sais jamais un tour en ascète
un petit cheval en d6 une petite dame
qui revient line tour elle regarde il
tout d'un coup il est très très mal
m'ériger gigote quand même un peu plus
qui acquit à 5 minutes coiffa qu'il ya
quelques années mais complètement 4 sait
pas ce qu'il fait par contre enfin ça
c'était la personne c'est ce qu'ils font
là tiens j'attaque fonction tiens je
reviens c'est terrible c'est terrible
mais c'est dur c'est avec une seconde
turbine noms nagy
on a vu dans la piscine qui a plus qu à
ses cheveux la chine a du bon car nul en
fait leur appétit siran ya c'est que ces
deux secondes connaissent pas leurs
atours france et 4 par contre s'ils
ratent tout cas et c'est là il avancé
mais c'est pas ce qu'il a fait fabien de
juste bouger le cul rincon ces pièces
oui qui prime c'est ce qui marchait pas
le jour de ce n'est pas un truc qui est
très réussi à avoir ce n'était pas
possible
ils étaient quatre oui la prime et c'est
dommage parce qu'il a raté des trucs
fabien en fait je prends des pions en
l'air de toi il est tellement pls avec
la pendule que il répète juste comme un
idiot pour cette noce d'or mais tu vois
je sais pas pourquoi ils le font pas
mais dans une cadence qui serait qui
pourrait être sympa aussi c'est faire
j'en rajoute de seconde à partir du 40e
coup lorsqu'une seconde vraiment c'est
tu tombes pas mais tu as le temps de
rien ben tu tombes pas assez tout mais
tu vois c'est encore un truc qui
ressemble au bullet et c'est encore un
truc qui part en faveur de 2,12 à quoi
vous avec le bullet ce réseau lui faire
mal ouais
pourtant il est jeune femme il a 28 ans
et les générations encore plus que de 1
ouais
après pour le coup je pense que
j'aimerais pas jugeons plusieurs
boulettes mais mais par rapport aux
autres joueurs comme ça et c'est pas son
truc comme ça mais lui sa grosse farce
et le calcul en profondeur en fait oui
et donc tu le retires du temps plus tu
retires sa grosse farce
alors après tout le reste il aura le
feeling ils savent à quoi il sait faire
mais alors aux maçons voilà c'est moi
son truc naturel là je t'annonce qui
connaît il est encore on a préparé je
veux tout impôt
je
ce qu'ils ont pu mais peut-être que
doodle va arrêter de rentrer dans ce
sens fait les deux premières sont bien
passées pour les pas encore in a une qui
l'a gagnée mais n'était pas trop bien
quand les hommes de son grand âge ça
mais globalement fait fabi m'a l'air de
le dominer là dessus n'est ce pas une
pièce en d5
iliad a mis trente sais pas je pense à
merde n'attendez retour le retour non
mais j'ai oublié le foot et 607 me
disais mais c'est sûr il te fais tout ça
tempo hisser en fait ce que tout avait
quatre c'est pas simple à voir tout le
monde ça tourne à l'est sur fou ou cinq
pas fou prend b5 tour prend 1,5 et tu
dois avoir un truc avec une est heureux
à la fin
ryoke et mais là il s'est forcément ça
se prépare ça c'est 100% sur tours h4
tempo il prend la décision tout de suite
or c'est une décision lourde de
conséquence fou des trois tours des
quatre tempo d'habitude j'aime direct
les chiens bon ton premier fruit de
quatre d'accessoires à b1 soit dames 1
bat profondemment ce pas con parce que
narrateur affoué système âme et auront
un des six d'un projet 6 ou prendre les
5 et aux investissements annoncés
dammers je crois bien un traître tu
passes ton temps qu'un poisson tu évites
l'épreuve 4 mais bon maintenant moi tu
fais une menace
mais du coup d'oeil il faut qu'il change
qui joue c'est dé 6,6 la quizième bien
faire souvent leurs deux chiens web on
le sait s'ils viennent c'est bien si
elle ne faillit fait sensation il aime
bien mais will they d'éthique ceci
laisse la tacc caresser truc comme ça
mais peut-être y a pas les mêmes prépa
en face
cela en fait tu te fais juste démonter
quoi une partie en trois minutes où tu
verras tout 25 coups tempo et il ya des
pièges partout il pourrait nuit danse à
la pendule et les mieux tout pour la
pression ça ressemble à la partie sale
habitude c'est quand même chiant la
scandinave
pas de chance ça me rappelle ce n'est
pas possible que famille et juge du mal
à jouer 10 à cause de la souris normes
ce qui n'est pas très bon en blitz sur
l'échiquier elles n'ont plus faim pas
très bon c'est relatif à welch allyn
urbain mondial parce que c'est beau mais
quand et numéro deux en temps normal
c'est que des moins bien copains
forcément bon après c'est pas encore
gagné dans tout ça tiens il est mieux
c'est clair mais doodles pas mal les
médecins font un pic à tremper chapelet
tour 17 du coup alors l'as tu prends ta
tanger quatre marques semaine en temps
j'ai quatre fous des deux tours d un
terrible
peut-être fait refouler de direct ou
moins sûr tourné un tacle ou trois
j'imagine il a pris ce projet katimavik
moi allez me faire flasher 4 enfin c'est
pas l'air terrible même moment il perd
pas tout la maison aujourd'hui acheter
tout ce que je veux dire c'est manger 3
ea fois j'ai l'air ok tu lorsqu'un père
terrible avait fait bon ça a l'air
terrible mais c'est sûr ces perdants ben
il va s'y de bouffées de fer h 5h 4h
trois autres comme ce match
après il était tellement mal après
l'ouverture c'est pas sûr qu'il ait
vraiment pire et sa position mais non
mais non moins voilà avec les plantes et
contentons vraies tâches matérielles
donc l'appareil pour les gens qui
débutent deux pièces qu'elle valait fou
c'est mieux qu'une tour je sais que
beaucoup de joueurs aiment bien aller
faire des cayes preuve de tout ça la
rend fou prend mais si vous pouvez vous
cavaliers civique une tour quasi tout le
temps c'est vraiment des exceptions
qu'on ne sait pas le cas
ouais mais là c'est un d'un point de vue
pratique c'est pas mal ce qui va faire
f5 et tout il peut encore y avoir des
pièges oued ou d'os est un bon mec en
pratique il prend bien ses chances aux
jeunes est il des gens bien calcule bien
riche et plein de choses pas mal quand
même parce que là ok c'est gagnant mais
ça peut être piégeur est ok pour le coup
ça c'est un des rares cas de figure où
la tour peut se battre quand elle est
tout seul face aux pièces puisque les
pièces art est mal et puis on passait
cependant là le truc c'est que les
blancs ont pas mal d'avancé
lavallée normalement il n'ya pas trop
d'espoir mais fo katiba f5 encore bas du
coupé a5 pour plonger 2b si c'est vrai
c'est que tu as truites auront du mal à
revenir à temps peut-être fou ou quatre
mains non moi je ferai aussi fou 4 je
t'ai pas f5 j'imagine pour tenter un
petit 5 abp set by a plus grand chose à
faire en fait juste b 7 des 8 tu vas
faire qui a aidé cette mouche 8,5 à
dambach encore tenté j'ai 5 g 4 f cfa à
chaque instant il se doit ouais mais
c'est pas si simple passe pas si simple
et merci à rigobert
merci beaucoup et 5 à 13 5 4 f3 pardon
et bloqué le des graines du fou ouais
ouais il va bloquer il va bloquer merci
pour pour les 10 à bien les chais sa
tante à fond kelly ou deux se valent et
mes vacances mais harry sur un jeu avait
prise 20 me guèye il a bien tenté
franchement c'est instructif ce qui a pu
implanter plus d'un avec sa avec son
truc ouais terrible terrible
terrible mais je pense quand je vois ça
vraiment je me dis qu'une bulle est sa
valeur que dans une position aussi tout
belicchi être arrivé à sa compagne r6
6,6 à reprendre chante un regard
d'elecam
mais yahia 6 6 et c'est chaud du coup
quand même parce que dans les ouvertures
il est très bien et donc mathieu nous
dit caillage 7 dans la partie d'avant
c'était nouveautés de coeur 1
c'est vrai que j'ai jamais trouvé mort
pendant cette partie là c'est pas du
talent et des grillages s'attelle en
fait comment il se retrouve tout en
gagnant c'est dans ces matches là refait
en fait
duda va dans le droit de critiquer il
est pas prêt pas c'est sûrement la bonne
gouvernance voilà ça sert d'être un truc
correct mais problème car on ajoute les
impôts dans la tranche mais que c'est
dur c'est le cavalier h7 là qui est une
nouveauté car alors il avait joué un peu
différemment ainsi davantage sont
d'accord il faut mais la tapa t'avais
pas qu'ils aient franchi 5
ça existe en fait c'était une pièce de
plus mais que roy h et enfin je voulais
dire en blitz un je voulais pas dit a
fondamentalement je passe te souviens je
crois qu'on avait vu le et plusieurs
années de cela les speechs sd à rognan
on a cas où souvent il joue et ça je
m'apprête à temps a vu des matchs est
souvent c'était lors des bas mais ça me
dit quelque chose un match plein comme
un conte a commenté avec toi avec ce
truc là ça me dit quelque chose
sajoo vous savez que les gens de photos
et de faire 3 h 24 pour vite ouvrir mais
les noirs ils ont le thon rouge et leroy
merlin
c'est compliqué c'est pour ça que c'est
pas rentrer tant parce que du coup il
doit bien connaître
falip ce camp bin ça donne envie hein
donc que tu vas le comté plus tard donc
la danse juste faire un point sur le
temps qui reste est ce que tu vas 35
minutes je me disais il sait on en a
déjà bon manger une bonne part du 3 + 1
c'est pas une vraie 1h01 arwen par
hasard qu'à la fin de cette partie on
aura mangé la moitié des game quoi moi
ça va j'ai serré on est content et ce
qui sera serré jusqu'au bout pour acquis
un vainqueur un jour ou l'autre je ne
m'exprimerai pas là-dessus fab nom qui
fait des cas at il prend le centre on a
quand même plus de ce suspect partie
avec icare ouais mais normalement en
fait le dernier match sans trop de
suspens celui de demain encore que il
peut quand même se passait quelque chose
parce que c'est guéri ouais non mais
guillon départ game gear artemiev et je
pensais 90 ou 95% mais c'est pas 100% en
fait qu'à retenir gagne et puis ce sera
pas 25 de non plus oui mais oui oui ça
pue au nez au début du match je lui dis
pas c'est gagné pas du tout et après les
quarts de finale mvl leeuwen aronian
monde façon là on aimerait que soit pas
serré victoire de m veine mais on sera
toutes façons content de suivre n'a qu'a
fait de cf n'a qu'à un truc séquelles
pour kippour qui va être ici millions en
fait pour les vannes
oui quand-même contemporain normal non
mais ça c'est quand même je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui seront pour
aronian sur ce chat à mon avis notre
notre représentant on veut pas on peut
pas laisser un joueur non mais voilà
bajau moment il ya quand même des
priorités pipi nice pompaire
saint-maxime dans ce match
la team pipi nice pampers en sueur
donc il y aura sa yoran à café dossier a
fait deux siècles quand même battu hier
un petit match qui se sont fait on s'est
tu n'as qu'à c'est à dire qui mais que
de siècle il est impressionnant est très
dangereux et très très dangereux
naka théoriquement contre artemiev
stepanakert de cfc conquis le deuxième
gp coupe de la caf et de cf
waqar hasan artemiev la corse et la
retenue oui ok malheureusement sa
démarche est sûrement trop de croire tu
aimes bien fumé monsieur et sow contre
duda ou caruana moi c'est sympa aussi
non c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
c'est un beau plateau c'était beau match
sera des beaux matchs et appréhendent me
tall théorique nacaso alors après ça
peut ne pas l'être mais théoriquement
c'est nacaso qui peut être très chaud
vraiment belkacem veille carlson way qui
peut être très chaud sur un toit c'est
ta queue dès maintenant c'est bien c'est
sympa c'est que après en finale tu
aurais naka mvl espérant que ça se passe
mieux qu'hier soir
voilà les chiens sont des créations
matin il est fort mais bon on fait dos
et ça m'a rassuré parce que le fixe sur
un match en 20 parties lui m il lui met
enfin en 18 parties du cou 11 et demi
cet ennemi ça veut dire que s'il est pas
en forme d'accueil peut vraiment perdre
contre fait d'os bon j'aime bien les
blancs jambes sont que caruana à la
surprise générale un problème dans les
ouvertures contre duda avec les noirs ce
qui est quand même étonnant alors est ce
qu'il veut ne pas montrer un truc des
candidats bah en fait non savait déjà
qu'on sait le match en étant très
confortables avec cette française en
doute a jugé qu ait lieu deux jeux
populaires comme avantage en ouverture
mais juste un autre type de position et
ça convenait pas à carreau n'a ni
réagissez mal pris
tu voi ont calé à 8 le par-5 eu des
mauvaises décisions commencé que juteux
type de pollution lui convenait pas ça
il faut plus de tentes pour entrer dans
le coeur du truc et trouver les bons
coups et donc il a soufflé sur cinq qui
est bonne ouverture qui maîtrise bien
aussi il va kirwan a il que je n'aime
pas le truc pas mal mais pour l'instant
à l'italienne
duda d'eyl ouais ménaka naka il a été il
est impressionnant hier contre maximin
franchement bien qu'avant il
m'impressionne vraiment très fort high
tech
ouais ils viivent habitants n'a qu'à
mais bon après maxime le truc c'est
qu'il veut pas à ses ouvertures aussi du
tout seul pour les matches amicaux
simple non c'est normal mais je leur
parle à c'est le fait de jouer des
ouvertures ou pas ça peut changer
beaucoup de choses
ça change pas mal bat été plus à l'aise
l'impression tallec ou naturels qui
viennent ça change pas mal puisque pour
maxime la nage darwin fait c'est quand
même un duo assez important et jouer aux
quatre avec les blancs aussi d'un du
coup il s'enlève quand même deux choses
importantes
mais bon on a été vraiment
impressionnant franchement là ils jouent
bien dormi mais bon il ya tenge qui a
bien joué son petit g4 et le deuxième
calife finale pourrait être 5 kg 3 sur
mandat fait une coupe h 55 peut-être
fourchette 5 par échec f3 sûrement quand
il veut puis normalement à l'autre bon
ok ça très bien non ce parti domine adha
elle a défoncé super courageux trois
marchés un fille bien je viens jodoin ne
rejoue pas cette noce d'or ce genre
juste fait un choix d'autres choses
voilà très bien c'est pas pour autant
qu'il va pas peur mais voilà petrov trop
facile avantage la petrov c'est que tu
peux pas être trop trop mal qua non bon
ben ça ok c'est devant être intéressante
c'est la variante la plus tendue en fait
donc car on va évidemment il connaît
très bien parce qu'ils la jouent là
petrov pendant un long moment
c'était son arme contre carlos et nos
matches de championnat du monde est
aussi ça a été avec ça que c'était
quelqu'un au candidat du jeu est
exclusivement ça pendant un an va dire
un nombre de dons qui connaît bien tous
tous les trios spéciaux et d'ailleurs
c'est te planquer 17 qui est si ce sont
les deux marques
je vais me dire
sa marque de fabrique mais donc dotation
partir pour soi damas cinq baies 5 des
trucs comme ça j'imagine
quatre des cinq gagne d'ailleurs quatre
concerts shows de bonnes options
auxquelles ces quatre afin que le joueur
américain revient à main de façon au
score la danse dans cette partie favier
j'ai peur en fait que si le doubs daf a
fait le break
maintenant ce soit vraiment fini
peut-être bien faut qu'on soit à fond
pour car warner france d4 sûrement quel
chouette facilement te désormais gérant
des quatre mois il va te faire des cinq
fois et six attaques
ouais mais bon peut-être je voulais
bouger tu peux aussi faire [ __ ] 4 x 4
ou c5 jeter n'importe quoi car ils n'ont
pas fait ça je comprends pas mais tandem
d4 d5 est ce que sur pc c'est sûr qu'il
a pensé sur quelque chose qui va pas + 1
est ce que tu vas te l'os c'est paul
pour les problèmes pendants est-ce que
tous les tops regarde c'est parti pour
les candidats ou ça n'a rien avoir du
tout alors ils peuvent jeter un oeil
mais honnêtement
bon en fait le truc ils ont des équipes
avec eux ils vont pas eux-mêmes perdre
15 heures à regarder ça mais moi les
secondes en évoquant même du tanet y
voir tiens qu'est-ce qu'il a joué tata
ont gardé un petit oeil dessus et ça
peut être utile
après c'est pas les mêmes cadences c'est
pas la même importance ou quoi donc on
se doute que mes bons arrêts qu'avec la
perte de confinement seyassah qui joue à
chaque fois non mais en plus le truc
c'est qu'en général et oui bien sûr les
mecs vont pas jouer lorsque vertus
rempli de sur internet comme ça mais en
même temps justement comme on pense à
ils peuvent peut-être l'attesté une fois
ou deux parce que tu vas prendre sa part
du village et environs façon il est
juste sur un tas tu vas pas le jouer et
voilages à ou même
par exemple je me souviens d'un think
you feel cup avant qu'ils vendent donc
des 1018 carmes scène avec les noirs ils
jouaient contre maxime et il avait joué
4 c 5 et 3 kgs c6
donc si vous appliquez ces trois salles
sont tous cas que cinq jécistes très me
rappellerai bon s'est dit ok bon justin
joue ça mais je rate jamais sa au
chocolat du monde on m'a choqué du monde
chez sony corp donc en fait des fois ils
peuvent toujours un truc ça passe un peu
inaperçu
enfin mme jouanno du web ont enfin fait
non donc c'est quand même fou quand même
il prêtait une certaine attention parce
que c'est vrai que c'est quand même tu
préfères enfin j'imagine même un réac
cac soit caruana maxime quoi tu préfères
avoir joué même si que trois quatre
parties en blitz sur toulon les douars
quand même venant des partis un peu
officiel ça donne un certain feeling jeu
c'est vrai tu sens tu sais un peu mieux
la position tu te poses des questions
tout n'être pas l'entraînement je sais
pas donc voilà qui c'est un bon chez
gbagbo en fait pas vraiment généralisée
mais en gros toutes ces parties là ça
c'est un certain intérêt malgré tout tu
peux sentir peut-être aussi que là il a
joué ça mais que ça veut dire qu'il a
duré des sous types de position même si
trop joue pas je vois pas exactement
même variante l'ours à des choses comme
ça mais moi mais c'est pas non plus la
panacée qua non non non normalement
elles vont patrouiller la notte du
siècle dans un match très bizarre
non c'est plus une question de red ed
c'est d'en tirer des déductions sur ce
qui pourrait jouer au delà des au delà
des partis et des nouveautés théorie
calmels exact mais là ça vient c'est
vrai de toujours rock opposé et c'est
les noirs qui vont attaquer en premier
ça a l'air d'être finir bc2 je suis
d'accord c'est terminé
en vo c'est pas propre jeu sur internet
ou quoi ça c'est juste que deux ont de
tout temps les joueurs doivent donner
certaines priorités à certaines parties
certain tournant sur d'autres
donc peut garder les nouveautés en
réserve pendant longtemps c'est
peut-être moins le cas maintenant
station quelqu'un va la sortir tôt ou
tard mais il y avait 30 ans de ça il ya
des mecs qui faisait exprès de pas jouer
le bon coup dans cette dernière fois
pour se garder en réserve pour la partie
qui compte après genre en finale tu vois
où en demi finale je regarderai quand
même un poil plus attentivement parce
qu'en finale
enfin c'est quand même un titre quoi
qu'il en soit quand même c'est pas rien
rien quand même
non messieurs voilà je veux qu'on arrête
de questions pas mes doutes allaient y
domine vraiment maintenant je sais pas
comment il doit finir mais en tout cas
ce qui est bien pour lui c'est qu'il
avait attaqué alors que les blancs n'ont
pas fait une seule manas sera
il ya plusieurs manières de jeu puis 1,4
a pas l'air au top de sa forme
c'est un b3 dame b cette barre est je
pense l espace appartient prend ces
trois c'est bizarre ce qui va te faire
[ __ ] en est le fou il va contrôler ce
b2 il va défendre il va attaquer à
d'accord est l'une des conséquences de
tout donner a qualité pour garder fourie
ce fouillis performant c'est vraiment un
intéressement sur ce qu'elle défend et l
attaque la pièce évidemment tu le gardes
et foulée 4chan survenu en d4 tant pis
tu donnes de qualité
la mairie suite à ça et à pains basten
qui est aussi ok j'ai essayé d'aller
mater voilà je comprends tu essaies les
cases noires à quelque chose pour vous
et changement c'est juan bonvalot
n'existe plus mais non tu dois être
mieux et ce qui prend 1,5
bon en fait ça encore finir on speed
le truc c'est que tu as quand même deux
pions avec les blancs donc si tu réussis
à tenir ça va parce que là en fait
j'avais chaque fois non j'aime bien ce
que je pensais mais ça c'est nul on tu
fais juste fou ici fauves et 5 en garde
pas regarder je regardais à et j'aurai à
mille autres en c4
bon ça va peut-être mais ça me paraît
bizarre juste de passes garder enfin tu
pourras voir la même comme ça quoi en
fait bon là tu vas faire c4 etc etc si
dans cet ovale sait pas encore mais
normalement ça va le faire mais je
t'annonce que s'il tient pas celle-là il
deviendra jamais aucune position parce
que ça c'est assez assez simple la lors
du dernier âge 5 gagnants carrément pour
les blancs à l'idée de jouer avec f3 est
monté mais tu vas il serait gardé le
pion à je pense que je joue quasi pour
gagner là déjà
ça va faire un nul à des familles qui
prend des risques et des grands risques
en attente et surtout avec 5 tours 5 a
tenté de la faire coller il tente de se
la faire coller en fait terrible il
reste combien de temps 20 minutes
bon ben on va pouvoir enfin elle qu'on
va vous pouvez tourner tous
bon c'est pas la phase la plus
intéressante du match ouais séparés mais
le h5 de l'ordi et efforts pour la
destruction tu montais les pions c'était
fini tu des rois j'assiste orageux suite
et de miroirs est le miroir c'est parti
est-ce quelques clics et des six autres
jugements moddeurs enfin mme houda ben
c'est pas un plan ce nom de ces six là
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est pas
caruana c'est pas vraiment ça sur
internet c'est en général en blitz et là
en plus il ya une section bull est donc
il est vraiment très désavantagé par le
format et ce serait pareil c'était sur
un vrai chic et c'est pas une question
d'internet pour pour fabiano
je pense par chivu section moins bien
envie de sur internet qui nous jouons en
réel non je crois que c'est assez je
sais pas exactement force g non mais là
puisque le match la star il ya un point
d'écart après après 15 parties oui c'est
surtout la section bullet qui doit des
avantages plus qu'autre chose ça et je
pense pas que intrinsèquement ce soit un
meilleur bilan que duda non je pense
vous avez bien lu ça mais il est bon de
son conjoint
je sais pas jusqu'où peut aller ou s'il
a déjà atteint son maximum fait mais
fallait qu'il améliore ses ouvertures en
tout cas et sur ce que je vois
aujourd'hui je peux dire ça a été fait
mais bon apple a le droit de cacher en
speech est sain ces affaires qui a aidé
6 maintenant nom moderne qu'à réduire le
foin f6 ouais donc c'est une pulsion de
pure isolé intéressante avec avec pu
isoler contre le pion s'est pas conclue
pions le coup donc il ya le foot est
très bien placé il veut peut-être
jacques est liée aux cinq probablement
d'air pour faire pression sur aix est un
peu alors qu'on dit que nemo le poisson
était favori contre aronian et ariane
l'a emporté très fort des motos et voilà
voilà bien nager quoi d'ailleurs il a
défoncé en ambulatoire oignons c'est ça
ouais mais les bonnes il avait avait
toujours mais il échoue il échoue faut
toujours avoir blague were ben je sais
pas pourquoi
pourquoi les pousser mes mots mais c'est
lui il écrit des mots c'est son pseudo
ok d'accord que j'ai dit oh bah qui
m'ont soir en émaux été favorisé les
mots le poisson très fort jouer et non
j'ai pas eu tort à son pseudo faucher
pas que les peaux abîmées recrue de
poids son salaire qu'il fait le plus
c'est ce qui avec à l'écriture
automatique des téléphones aux yeux de m
pro prono m porno ça me fait rire sanaa
un prono pour le match ce soir
voilà ça l'arbalet pour les noirs ils
ont plus ou moins stabilisé leur truc
ouais merci aux open kata ce non non non
je prendrai les blancs mais je veux dire
par rapport à vos poubelles qu'il a eu
avant vim
je sais pas tu suite dé 3,5 c'est bien
je suis vieux jeu non mais là c'est bien
ça le km5 c'est bien mais pas mal car
elles ont eu 5 mais bon ça doit aller
pour les noirs aussi s'aimer ben tu en
plus facile à jouer avec les blancs ces
trucs là puis isolé je vous c'est
tellement dur de jouer contre cantal
puis on sait si ce lieu de six
tu as l'impression cette pression là qui
est pénible sur la diagonale il faut
bien de se bouger
c'est en fait le jour c'est six fois
pour bilodeau sysomos a donné liberté de
caisse blanche mais en fait il fait pas
tellement de choses
la balle j'ai relevé sur les noirs et en
réussite mais le mans b 7
il est bien et ça demande un peu ton roi
à la torah et pas trop blindés
je sais pas vous mais ça ne basons ou f4
quoi mais c'est bizarre ce qui fait ça
c'est logique avec les blancs ils
voulaient attaque à fond
moi mes skis à base de kaki coup ça
c'est une autre question
mais le truc c'est qu'il a faim
tellement bons plans là avec sa tour l'a
tellement mergelas caruana je crois
qu'il a très bien joué cette partie
vraiment l'italien sur cette partie des
origines reviennent ça va il peut
égaliser 1
ils seront mieux vraie pizza et la télé
pizza pizza et pizza royale avec de la
nana ce genre de truc quoi sais c'est
pas possible c'est clueless que dans une
pizza avec de l'ananas
mais mathieu laine bien j'ai jamais
goûté de ma vie en fait mais c'est que
vous n'est ce que l'on se bat non je ne
sais pas ça c'est bizarre je n'ai même
pas envie d'essayer en fait mais il
paraît que c'est pas mal à moi par
principe en fait ouais mais moi un peu
je dis madame ça ressemble c'est laisser
le début de la déchéance en fait bouger
cinq ans est logique on savoir
ouais mais je n'avais pas trop juger la
position mais écoute vu l'avant sautant
ch mais très câlin favori c'est quand
même 50 secondes contre 5 dans une
vision très très chaude cette partie là
elle est importante un way point de
revenir aussi très peu on pouvait le
voir partir h sam est vrai que ça
sûrement se tournent de travers et si tu
fais roi prend il faut donner à la fois
de la women's oublie le fou et du coup
un répit mais pas telle qu'elle est mais
est-ce que tu prends vraiment lotus
je sais pas quel os tu prends un diable
jeu de dames ça va bien qu à leur
disposition ouais mais là ça peut-être
joué fatigue que cinq secondes en fait
parce que quand elles qui prennent cette
tout ça l'est probablement un truc à
faire
il a joué tour à tour de t'imaginer il a
joué avec quelques anomalies 00 c'est
incroyable il a joué avec moins d'un
dixième
kiddo d'habitude le site mais perdant
quand tu fais ça c'est incroyable
quoiqu'il ait pas perdu mais bon il va
perdre la position juste oui c'est trop
trop mauvais c'est sûrement vrai
j'espère que j'ai quatre pour coincer sa
c5 ensuite tout d'abord bon sens et
c'est même mieux en fait de prendre ces
cinq d'avoir mais à quoi bon je crois
que tout est bon ou pas j'aurais du mal
à voir compte pas pas gagné ça mais
coûte 80 encore doux dingue c réactive
et le roi de il est chiant ça c'est bien
finalement ce gigote à fond c'est pas
sûr que le bal a du coup c'est gagnant
ou pas pas sûr jack est ici je dirais
que non parce que c'est fort quand même
beaucoup bloquer le tout souvent et le
roi va courir très vite en cellule mais
caruana quand même pas très bien géré
puisque c'est vrai que son truc très
logique de va se prendre g4 et à
mais bon ah bah je sais pas c'était
mieux enfin j'étais réactiver doha de
l'autre côté ça veut dire ça vient mais
monture et c'est peut-être un détail
pour pour pour les gens mais ça veut
dire beaucoup quand même qu'il est qu'il
est sauvé sa cellule un possible
problème fait pour ceux qui débutent
sexy et noire poussent leurs pions sur
seule chance de gagner c'est d'aller à
dame
il ya un fou trompions et 6 coupé au
quai vallet voilà c'est ça être pas
autant de demande si monsieur que j'ai
joué à des montois de cannes en 2006
non en fait il reste deux parties en
trois plus un fab et c'est plus sain
pour duda et maintenant ça se fight sur
les petrov au fond ouais bah allez faut
que caruana égalise ici
ok les gars drogués les faits à trois
ans je crois donc l'effet que les quatre
aventures c5 dida ne lâche rien c'est
chaud et c'est beau de sa part web après
c'est un peu son jeu aussi un de toit
des ressources de trouver des ressources
fabiano c'est pas son point fort en plus
de films la finition en partie rapide
bien jeux d'eau devant alors trouvé ça
sympa mais ok pas besoin d'un peu raté
mais c'est aussi lui qui a su trouver
taille comme d'ailleurs la partie où il
est il a poussé ses pions fgh qu'il ait
quand même fini par peur mais en fait tu
as un truc pour pour te faire chier
quand il est foutu
mais c'était sûr qu'à force temps normal
créer une à un moment donné de façon à
ce que déjà atteint enfin quand il a
poussé flash lite autant près 1
bref 5 des 4 vous pensez que c'est pour
cela que je vais pas m'étendre magnus or
ça je suis pas du tout au courant s'il
joue pas je sais pas qui joue et en
allemagne où c'est toi tu sais peut-être
plus barrés du dévoilement par jour vous
pourrez regarder nous les hans ont ce
genre par nom qui est vrai je savais que
y avait dit n'gahane c'était le premier
nom annonce elle mais avec l'europe et
il a peut être annoncé peut-être si je
rappelle pour les tournois se veut pas
dire que l'on jouera aucun enfin c'est
la saison dernière il avait joué des
trucs de mémoire ou un donc je peux prix
jouera pas ou alors ils focalisent à
fond pour préparer les comptes je sais
pas j'ai pas assez eu 15 + 10 et cadence
qui lui corresponde ont plus ouais ouais
non ou alors je sais pas franchement
j'ai bien sympa que je vais faire son
nombre de salles je sais vous plaît tu
dois devront se mettre d'accord sur les
conditions financières
je sais pas de juste des trucs comme ça
c'est possible et qu'ils vont se mettre
d'accord à un moment ou pas donc j'ai
trois ya préparé h 4 h 5 1 tout bêtement
eux ils échangent étoiles a vendu lui
l'avenir encore eu de suite très vite à
l'espace faire après c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout a de la joie pour tous
les tuer du temps ouais bah ouais bah tu
es devant au match tu es plus fort un
plus un
ça paraît assez logique hein
mais pour éviter on ne parle plus parce
que fait il reste combien de temps je
vais avoir le crown rs 7 30
ouais t'as envie de la jouer une ou deux
minutes de plus quoi fabien qui propose
nul accepter qu'il n'a pas voulu faire
le truc salle s'ajoutent à ça je vous
fair-play des quatre première fois
c'était que 2k département oui mais il
est peut pas être heureux de voir la
petrov
ça peut se comprendre
ouais non non c'est bien de changer un
peu ça nous fait voir autre chose
on a beaucoup joué à l'ouverture pour
l'instant je change un peu quitte mizuho
qui par le racing aurait pas joué si
fair play dans un match serré qui l'ont
rafeal ce qui était génial c'était sous
la dernière fois
thiam et lui donner mais c'est génial
que je voulais même pu gagner les
parties en fait je voulais faire durer
le plus longtemps possible elle étaient
ses cendres eastick partir dîner chez
moi ça j'en ai marre je veux rejouer le
moins possible que rester warrants comme
défi d'être mieux pour faire durer bien
bien comme il faut quoi
bon à trois soirs où ça c'est de se
demander qui est des trois quoi tu
forces vous prend 6 x 5 et b4 voiture
prend du fonds c3 et ya pas de calais 3
il faut en d4
voilà bien placé mais ont rejoint plus
isolé mais plutôt sympa pour le bon si
tu reviens pas peur de fouet à +
bloqueurs même si tu le perds en fait y
aura beaucoup de pièces échangées
exactement moyen de pièces mieux c'est
pour les blancs web et les biens partent
je pense qu'il est très bien que déjà
c'est une partie où tu as des chances de
perdre et tu vas juste travailler au
corps transversale ok donc c'est bien il
va faire durer la dame plutôt parce que
sinon tu fais le cahier prends tu avais
pas d'âme b3 à cause des idées de ces
chiens ou touré 21 probablement après
deux trêves ton cas veillez tu mettras
de fond f3 dame 520 me semble
on va voir comment c'était beau
techniquement peut-être que c'est
important en fait ce que ça peut être
deux points d avance
disons qu un point d avance il est déjà
énorme favori de points d'avancé fait le
break et les plus forts en bulles est je
pensais c'était 7 termine le match où
quasiment tous des trois ok ça soit ya
beaucoup de bons coups pour les blancs
faut pas trop se presser il ya une
faiblesse dans le camp adverse on va
retourner autour l'attaqué peut-être
comprennent seront donc c'était un après
que même poussé dans ton roi je crois
pas que ce soit le cas de figure où tu
peux pour le mans ouais dames le symbole
religieux comme ça aussi en longues
sûrement pas parce que tu dois sûrement
garder les dames facile de gagner mais
en blitz je trouve que c'est très bien
que ça comme ça est ce qu il a à ce
point plus fort que caruana ambühl a dû
down under en il va être plus fort du
coup s'ils partent à égalité ou caruana
un peu de vent c'est une chose mais plus
de ces pas anodin il va y avoir huit
partis qui doit tu dois gagner le truc
vallières neuf parties tu dois gagner le
truc 6 3 c'est pas facile en fait non
utopie ou un film ou deux on ne concède
pas une partie d'échecs à venise quad on
sait par un jeu de s'activer sur la
colline c'est la tête qui avait laissé
cinq tours prend à celle qui est proche
voilà aussi ce qui allait prendre et
troyes et tours sermat en fait que se
passe-t-il en cas d'égalité finale on
rejoue quatre bulles est peut-être faire
tourner dans ce set quand on pense à ce
temps s'est vite tu t'en vas nulle a
prévu le match s'est passé c'est une
décision compréhensible 1 3 minutes
il ya quoi comme ça en quarante secondes
une 40 ça peut être là lundi trois
puissants ou pas
dur à dire sur encore une partie
derrière y est maintenant là il reste de
40 noms normalement ça dépend ça dépend
s'il lui joue pas
soudas douala joueur tu t'es aux bulles
est réputé bien content la partie
d'avant je comprends tu fasses nul c'est
en fait objectivement c'est vraiment du
respect c'est enfin de vraies décisions
de genre d'échec la juste eu peu de dire
je joue un jour mais pourquoi tu joues
bas pour passer le temps allez plus tu
trouve la réponse à la question est
toujours à toi mais pourquoi tu joues
pour passer le temps
bon cerveau qui est c4 pas pour le coup
là tu as déjà aucune chance de gain
c'est que même qu'avec contre fout c'est
nul ça ouais je sais mais c'est ça super
tournée tu peux te faire plaisir tu veux
tourner mais la partie ii capable en cas
content j'ai pu qui flore peut-être je
pense ou en fait je signale quoi je
crois que tout les pions sur noir et le
fou qui rôdent tf6 g7 puis six à sept là
ils font 17
par exemple je vais changer les
cavaliers ça reste toujours un peu mieux
ces nullards se décidera faire si
ceux-ci ne savais pas du tout où 8 août
mais rennes c'est un pion sur jean yves
est encore flou mais trois fois vii 4
alors attends il reste combien de temps
une 0,8 à mais il faut qu'ils les choux
c'est hyper important
non mais pas
peut-être mais en plus tu as des chances
d'être une sorte de zizou angoisse parce
que cela m'a pris mais pas le fou
puisqu'il a foutu c'était faux et 8
pouces et 6 mai faut 8 g/l fonds à 4 ha
pardon pardon président c'est ça ce que
je voulais faire de base aussi mais ça
qu'il faut prendre huit donc le monde
est confuse et mal vu mais mais du coup
c'était faux f 5 x 6 ouais mais du coup
après deux titres seront qu'un peu de
faire des doubles et de croire des coûts
de merde je sais pas h3 je suis pas en
fait je vais assez sévère bizarre parce
que tu te les autres a pas eu à suer
pour gagner le pion à la même pas
vraiment vu en fait c'est possible que
ce soit nul encore c'est possible mais
je sais pas enfin bon piaf à blocage
sans caisse doit inclure en deux sets la
bonne nouvelle pour les blancs c'est que
le pion à enfin c'est une case blanche
on évite donc il n'ya pas les caves et
deux nuls
à voir c'est peut-être nul mais bon en
tout cas clairement il va jusqu'à la fin
du temps ça c'est sûr mais il essaye de
remonter un peu hot en tournicotant mais
rien ça va être nul car il doit faire un
blocus battu fédérer blocus et kroos est
cassé la dernière là ça va être la
dernière de la militante des petits
pièges qui chipe oui contre intel tu
sais ça peut passer
il va faire aux cinq un moment monsieur
prévost va te cacher loin parce que
j'aime pas les reds cet aprem où c'est
une autre affaire où cette avancée
conquois fast food et 5 x 8 tu peux pas
faut habitants ya pas de quatre figures
où tu peux pas non à force de vouloir
maintenant y'a pas d'autres partis
désolé mais à force de vouloir remonter
autant il n'a pas fait cinq fois
ouais incroyable que ça ait fait time's
up c'est rare
j'ai ça vraiment le gong et le times est
directement et donc lors du même tour de
belote 30 une demi heure 38 de bullet
après on est bien sûr ça va
l'or n'est pas trop sûr avec un point
d'écart bah oui ça fait pas plaisir
c'est pas assez là n'ont d'ailleurs je
suis même pas si le match sera il ya
gotham cias qui intègre issa l'ufab
[Rires]
c'est pas d'ma faute et j'ai passé le
sceau du gua web comme c'est serré mais
voilà c'est serré et on va voir
l'éventuelle chute à la de fabiano bah
là ce serait quand même un assez gros
exploit qui gagne sur les bulles être
pas pu tous conduits de terre
retrouverait tellement en fait ils
gagnent sur les bullet bataille mais ce
possible je suis pas ne trouve plus
grande ou doit il défend bien il est
chiant il a les qualités qu'il faut pour
ça rien h 1
rien en toilettes
il va se défendre de ou fin c'est sur
ces successions duda ouais nan d'oudalle
gros favoris tu vois moi je le mettrais
à 1,05 chez les bookmakers
duda avant le bullet la même moins 1,30
moi j'ai divisé 0,5 1,5 non tu prends tu
prends tu prends à tu comptes de même 1
30 ans tu prends tous les jours un
indice à mon avis tu commençais à
réfléchir mais les bookmakers ils font
une marge
score final moi je mettrais +4 duda moi
je sais pas moi non mais bon je pense
qu'ils y gagnent aussi mais bailan
adjoint davantage suis pas quoi te pend
sur aulas tu es pas sûr donc en gros si
c'est est ce que tu es en train nous
dire c'est que si c'était toi a dit je
mets pas quoi 1,30 je prends elle a
aussi dire que tu es quand même déçu du
format je suis pas très sûr grichting j
+ 1 kg 10 + 4 non plus gêné plus 4g pas
les plus sains et plus 4 bat quelqu'un
dit je te suis plus cinq mais je paye
plus simple et plus quatre heures qu'il
va gagner de 3 points la section but
l'adresse bac + 4 oui pardon j'ai tous
ces chefs bas noté soit toujours su
qu'il me souhaiterait mais souhait ouais
ben écoute on va voir c'était un match
sympa mais on sait pas trop trompé son
nom c'était sûr et demain du coup ce
sera sympa parce que peut-être le le
gastronome en culottes courtes va perdre
probablement oui quelqu'un il va
probablement perdre
on va voir sait jamais mais ouais en
fait j'aime bien c'est un téléphone qui
t'as qu'à te refaire un break et a tapé
la balle probablement up de coupe il n'y
a plus cette référence plus
interférences parfait non ré demain
artemiev c est sympa je pense que babu
favoris et la web au doute je sais pas
1,25 qu'est ce que c'est être c'est vrai
coach est pas à 25 je mets en ligne tout
de suite à 1,25 duda alors là je
réfléchis même pas en fait à 1,15
réfléchi 25 s'affiche à même pas 20
avant que ma main je mets aussi en
dessous je n'ai peut-être pas les normes
déjà
non mais je tiens il me demande quand
auront lieu les quarts de finale non
c'est pas non mais c'est free money à 25
bon bah du coup peut dire qu'il va
gagner
ouais mais un 15 5 1 c'est plutôt free
money à 1,10 et jamais plus rien est ce
qu'elle est et où les échecs sont
interdits c'est possible ah bon ah ouais
bah oui une fatwa contre ma el fatwa je
sais pas s'il est toujours de mise
cette voie mais très possible mais c'est
un jeu de chance donc c'est un jeu de
chance
rageux qui met les hommes les uns en
face des autres 1,10 à problèmes mais
quel jeune mais pas les hommes en face
les autres les échecs les matchs de foot
tu les mets un peu aussi quelque part
allez y croire après un ballon du coup
ça mais les hommes contre le ballon
c'est le ballon qui se fait défoncer au
foot ouais mais là encore après des
pièces en cours au niveau doigts courent
après enfin faites attention nombre
d'accords guardian et le point les
échecs interdit par le grand mufti
d'arabie saoudite gaza
ces zombies et bien interdits oui à des
pays où c'est un travail en oeuvre de
satan sur les cas où les paris donc
ouais les pays où c'est interdit
vous imaginez parier sur les échecs ou
là là mais historiquement c'était aussi
interdit en occident les échecs par par
l'église d'ailleurs au xième siècle au
12e siècle c'est interdit c'était quoi
déjà la raison par assas fait perdre du
temps au lieu de travailler ou de prier
einstein aurait très très content bravo
l'église mais il y avait beaucoup de
prêtres et de gens d'église qui joue aux
échecs en fait
donc ça a été il ya plusieurs périodes
historiques ou les échecs ont été
interdits dans des régions du monde
diverses langues est seulement sont
encore interdits à certains endroits non
mais sérieux et ça c'était une diffusion
chaotique voit pas partout pareil en
même temps que c'est un ouais je me
viennent après que c'était pour beaucoup
de choses comme ça aussi à cette époque
là
accueillir au yen à nos bd je pense que
ça revient là bon donc du coup toi tais
toi tu dis à 1,25
moi j'ai mis un 0-5 en vert on va dire
que si il finit à entre +2 et +3 tu
avais raison
à partir du scad c'est moi qui ai raison
allait trop k plus k simagri n'y a plus
qu'a t il ya une faille si facilement tu
es content a pris 1,25 c'est un peu
serré et est dégoûté bas qu'en juillet
pour paris je vais te dire on va voir on
va voir le scénario quand même un
scénario en 25 était quand même pas
content enfin à 25,6 à égalité à dix
minutes de la fin tu es quand même pas
content ça
on verra on verra qui a raison parce
qu'en fait tu peux cash out ou quoi
c'est l'égalité à 8 minutes
t'es pas bien quoi n'intervient du
cheshire aux mêmes heures au final si tu
gagnes quand ces sites et réseaux plus
d'ascenseur émotionnel c'est quoi ça ces
codes du match qu'elle du match on dise
quoi il le matin ils mettent que 60% que
60% à duda mois favori maintenant que ce
qu'ils étaient avant le match ouais
c'est terrible là c'est vraiment free
money un jazz comme sur roulettes
monfils chez ce cas leur truc avec des
sortes de snake style douteux met donc
en fait il a était favori du match à un
moment donné en fait car voilà 3 0 à 4 1
je pense c'est la 4 1 et après il a fait
il a chuté et que les actions caruana
ont chuté 1
c'est terrible hélas sa série de
défaites en fait ne pas confondre le
prix et la valeur de l'action caruana
attention moi je pense que c'est anti
fragile un quart fut sa caste puis tu
fais casser annoncé ça a donné encore
plus solide antiphrase mais c'est
fragile
c'est exceptionnel s'est sentie
fragilité gars extraordinaire à puce est
chaotique à une bombe atomique mais
senti fragile donc avant tout cas tant
ce thème quelle guerre calque hawaï d'où
tu connais anti fragilité charismatique
bercy on se renseigne que ça on se
renseigne bon sens elle séparera de
covin on veut qu'on veut ça ce qui est
anti fragile quoi ces indemnités je sais
pas ce que ça n était en fête enfin ça
va être un truc très pointue et tous et
nous on a un nom la stratégie donc ça va
nassim nicholas taleb may 13 heures et
lors des parties fait très mal aussi
mais j'ai adoré le nom que le concept
corse a été exceptionnel tu fais tomber
avant l'épisode du solide c'est
extraordinaire enfin averti puis super
content je venais aussi c'est génial
mais je pense mais ce concept doit
rendre absolument toutes les personnes
du monde ça n'existe pas en fait mais
donc du coup google est on si fragile
jusqu à un certain moment délicat ça
concède anti fragilité est maintenant
c'est tu tombes c'est de mieux en mieux
mais en fait peut-être à un moment donné
à tout le monde en fait c'est bien
fragile
ah ouais tu viendras celle inverse quand
tout va bien en fait t'es bon alors là
les amis c'est ce qu'ils font
ces vagues qui a inventé les échecs les
gars bah oui tout le monde c'est la
dream team fragile d'ailleurs puis puis
braves ont été pour r jade évidemment
comment ont-ils découvert le secret bon
ça reprend pas pour le moment mais on
sait pas ils font quelque chose
bon d'accord ça donne un goutte et ils
repartent
il repart sur un truc tory je pensais
qu'ils changeraient pour le bullet d'une
à mes amis à petrov cela vient aussi
pour l'instant c'est sicile et à l'eau
il prenait un peu le pas je vois il joue
un truc c'est à la ruine voilà je suis
pas quoi en fait
mais du coup et ça peut être dangereux
en fait si si je vous la théorie que
l'autre connaît à fond un palace
tonio292 je sais pas trop ce que c'est
l'idée mais une idée au début ils vont
des deux il faut juste qu'ils
réussissent à jouer vite en fait qu'à
roanne ex pas ne pas trop la tête qui
parle qui se perdent pas dans ses
calculs puisque de façon il a les bons
réflexes à paphos qui joue vite et bien
c'est pas non plus pas beaucoup de monde
est en fait faut pas qu'ils partent
malaf aufray qui gagne la première a
directement au moins faire nul de gagner
une partie même c'est important de
recoller au score et d'être d'être
dedans quoi
le blizzard ce qui est en train de faire
ce qu'a fait que ceci peut être m dames
en face simplement n'ai pas d'écho en
plus du coup quand tu es cahier des cas
tu fait prendre par le pion à temps il
va pas faire un c'est moi qui ai cliqué
en il a fait pousser six médailles en a
quatre prises prise blesse c'est
catastrophique non déjà c'est le vrai
métal qui ont des cartes non ça va en
fait non mon goût tu prétends rien que
les blancs la presse et du bullet train
tu joues devant l'as tu prétends plus
rien je t'accorde que la prétention est
terminée ouais c'est complètement égal
mais après tant que tu perds pas bien
plus qu'un animal style alors comment ça
évolue mais ça ça joue à faire annuler
mais bon après en bullet to peut
t'arriver un fable ouais bien sûr mais
bon là quoi je vois mal
bon allez tu peux faire à 4 à 5 des
quatre des cinq créations passées
non sûrement pas on est bien sûr à mon
avis ça va faire nul mais on est bien
sûr celle et du coup ça fait quoi
non je sais pas si tu joues trop
convaincre et blanc tu veux quoi on sert
à des problèmes un doublé c'est faire le
même bruit pour voir si je mais non ça
va m'avoir écouté le pion à f/5 était
déjà le roi qui rentrent mais attendait
4 ouaf ouaf 6-3 f3 non mais des
conneries comme ça on sait mais tu vas
acheter entre est en fait très froid
pranger 3 tu t'en fait pas attention il
faut faire puis je ne serai pas trop
ravi qu'il faut croire f54 est un pion
de moi at elle précisé c'est pas faire
encore
bah prend forme oui non ça prend forme
mais c'est pas mayroy h3c quoi le vrai
qu'il faut se forcer chance tu as les
deux pions passer ca
mais surtout ces deux promotions pas
céder c'est fini la mamie angers 4e
le cvu à la caméra qui n'a pas vu le roi
prend h 4 juste ok si même ça tu perds
non mais là c'est tout toi je pense car
à 25 je suis content là bas je suis très
heureux voilà
kevin kevin la fla là le bookmaker fap w
non super ça ils vont perdre beaucoup
là c'est plus deux là les états unis en
sueur backing terrible arrêt mais c'est
terrible mais je veux qu'ils pensaient
qu'à roanne elle est passée largement en
réalité je pense y démarre les bullet
avec un gros avantage est tout si l'été
démarre à +3 +4 ça je suis sûr qu'il a
perd pas en plus c'est c'est pas pareil
de démarrer une section de bullet avec
quatre points d'avancé avec un point de
retard
non c'est pas c'est pas la même chose un
nom mais le problème c'est que je sais
pas en fait un leader il a joué trop
négligemment parce qu'évidemment c'est
très très nul que la position
regardez même plus trop ce qui se
passait il a consacré un chemin pour le
roi d'heure c'est et puis voilà quoi à
l'appui on prend les affaires tout
reprend mais ça c'est typique de nouveau
les positions et à y envoyer 2,4 dans la
gueule ya le fou qui va faire il joue
pour soi un peter tut fetwa autres sont
une envie de le faire ah non ça va faire
mal fab leucate tourache 800 kw un coup
oui non je pense tu dois faire un bond
qui vont ça ça peut chauffer et de 2950
bullet mais juste il ya eu là le
les 150 points qui ont été donnés cercle
à son lots actuelle en bullet comme les
150 points de surévaluation c'est moins
que mon mac sont bull est en réalité ce
que j'ai eus donc pas je suis quand même
pas un monstre enfin genre mon max en
blitz et 28 43 et eux leurs beaux lots
en blitz et 3050 donc le fait que mon
mac soient supérieurs m'ont lots de
maximum dans la cadence soit supérieur
au sien actuellement ça veut dire
beaucoup en fait c'est tout bon non mais
tu vois c'est pas possible pour pour
lutter face à des joueurs pareillement
heureusement qu'il ya le plus une
seconde mais quand même ça ça change de
trois trucs une seconde puis une seconde
change quelques cheveux quelques petits
trucs mais bon pourquoi pas
c'est bizarre mais ça file pas juste se
fit la baraque
je sais pas ce qu'il a vu et il est
toujours très qu'il a des idées
pratiques je ne sais pas ce qu'il va y
voit plus ça c'est bizarre fois ce qu'il
a fait mais elle est même très étonnant
après ils peuvent prendre des mauvaises
décisions aussi parfois th3 up
oui je sais j'ai vu mes mots car il y
avait trop à coeur 3 il est où partout
nord-est partie duda enfin pour finir
fables of table of life 4 mais bon tant
duda il ya tellement sauver des trucs qu
un sauveur chaleur que option et c'est
en plus mais bon il y avait place très
mal placé ben c'est ça c'est
objectivement gagnant mais la fête un
soutien au passé qui avancent déjà c'est
autre chose et puis je sais pas quel
point son corps quand on gagne en même
temps c'était il prend la mouche pas
encore une fois car la taqiyya dit tout
ça c'était écrasant la voilà c'est pas
sur le roi le roi c'est fait
rob lowe pied sur assist c'est fou ces
six c'est pas encore ça
w quoi d'autres caravanes à perdre la
fable w la double action qui perdent pas
d'accord j'ai même envie de dire sa
femme soit sa baisse
bref bon c'est beau c'est terminé en
baisse à kevin love
kevin love football caf docteur doudou
diop au cycle alors là c'est trop
ça devait se terminer comme ça les gars
ça s'est senti là perdu le match qu'ils
ont tissés faits remontants 5 + 1 en
fait voilà qu'en tunisie 4 1 4 1 à 3 0
la balle de 4-0 et à 84,2 le petit
cratère âge après la trop à 4,3 aussi la
craque elle a de nouveau une bonne
position qu'il a perdu près sûr sur
cette séance sur cette séquence la cua
du entre le 3 0 et le et le 4 4
il était mieux sur pas mal de parties il
en a perdu perdu trop mais il a aussi
bizarre d'admirer klaxon final jean le
140 oui pas pour un joueur de ce niveau
se lit pas tout ce qui se fait
complètement plier par duda chaque fois
qu'ils partent très loin celle là il
partait de et enfin ok il a simplement
posé avant auront la cfu là celle-là
c'est incroyable aussi
et déjà avant dans les cadences un peu
plus lente non mais là il peut pas y
faire b trois fois à cinq blessés voie
lactée
il va faire glisser trois quais
mais en tout cas soit 5 fast face dans
l'air qui est à 2 à passer longtemps
là-bas non mais s'est trouvé le contrôle
de l'autre côté assez bien joué ça va
remettre le caire en d3 et quand il a
plus de temps il s'organise bien il se
met les pièces où il faut 9 mai d'apple
bizarre mais c'est bien parce que
sous-tend la pile et janry les mâles et
tout de suite si te pousse les pions il
rentre avec son roi fins et les chiens
ni talent
c'est incroyable parce qu'en fait en
début de finale c'est lui qui est proche
de la perdre avec les noirs en tout cas
proche de souffrir et c'est lui dans ma
tête je ressens chaque phase active de
fou mais qu'aucun ne bouge pas enfin il
va probablement pas su gagner celle là
ce questionnement qui peut gagner en
select et noir ouais il peut pas prendre
des cats kaka et des trois échecs il ya
ma l'otan pourra caruana us et bien il
se prend plus des re 2 4 à 4 h à pied 5
est tombé 3 et après à la fin quand tu
en gagnes ou trois pour vous tu veux
faire crisser un rêve de d4 et bing en
fait ouais du cui par là bas elle sait
bien jouer roi des huns du coup
c'est fou parce qu'à ces costauds quoi
mais soudain il lui met des phases où
d'un coup il accélère la barre il joue
vraiment exceptionnellement bien du
talent ces phases là il y avait un petit
fou prend 1,3 sur carré les prend il ya
plus on prend et qui allait prendre b4
jugé en soit je devrais pas dire ça ou
tu prends et fou j'ai un flash devrait
pas je pourrais le faut c'est vrai mais
souvent c'était gris tchouk en interview
qui disait que duda lui faisait penser à
un vieux frites leur fritz 3 ou quoi
ouais je me rappellerai pas très bien
préparés aux ouvertures mes calculs très
bien pas palau sant jordi actuelle mais
que ok c'était une pomme canada gris
choo de sa gueule et ça veut dire ça
quand même dire que pour le battre c'est
chaud j'ai toujours trouvé les
ressources et +4 puisque atlas est
vraiment terminée surtout vu le scénario
oracle a maintenant il tente trouée
longuenesse italienne vendent peu
d'audace amish est la preuve des cinq
tireurs sportifs qui +5 je vais avoir
raison et ça peut même faire plus ça
après l'attaqué du champ de quito
classique fasciste h 4 h 5
il se faire via décroché mentalement
enfin je sais pas si c'est vraiment
décroche je trouve pas je trouve qu'il a
fait son match il a il a juste une une
phase où il a manqué de réussite 1 c'est
un peu comme au foot si tu as les
occases tu tapes une fois sur le poteau
l'autre fois ta but refusé sur hors jeu
alors qu'il y ait puis c'est fini coiffe
un cap agricole en quoi j'ai pensé que
ça a pu être le scénario du match de la
france il ya eu tellement d'occasions
ouais c'est ça il ay là il a eu des
occases ou au tennis parfois ta balle de
set
elle tombe à 3 centimètres de la ligne
et des ratios de faire retourner enfin
c'est un peu ça mais bon on bulle être
trop fort en bullet et est même en
ratant un peu son début de match de son
côté ça suffit mais il a eu les
circonstances de partie en sa faveur
quand même 12 à ce que tu as aronian par
exemple compte n'est pas de manière
assez incroyable s'est jamais faire
tourner mais tu vas te le disais c'est
un peu l'inversé ça sert à rien un peu
inverse genre en fait tu te fais pas
retourné tu as réussi à les tenir coi
hélas ici
bon ça partout il s'active et que ces
cavaliers quelqu'un ou trois shoots et
jean luc hess blanche 25 un jour mon
gars je trouve ça intéressant ce qu'il
fait il fait sa partie la lessive avoir
une micro champ soit absolument la
gagner ça là où là c'est bien ça c'est
craquage n'ont pas l'air bien ces
détours arriver
était plus apte à court passage à
thatcher mais sans savoir d'où il ya
encore un nom
j'ai pensé que que c'était craquage mais
en fait peut-être pas craquage du tout
je pense à elle m'a très bien joué d'un
projet 2 bon ça vaille à 9 secondes en
plus mais travaille cette partie où il a
monté son radeau folie il s'est jamais
fait mater ça me rappelle ça fait
comment est ce que dans cette position
avec ton roi qui est complètement pourri
tu as réussi à te retrouves à un moment
donné dans cette position là en fait
d'un bâton sans grand entrain de tourner
ça incroyable et aux atours échec et roi
des cats et ça termine le game tu va
bouffer tous les pions et non mais à un
moment donné c'est incroyable d'avoir
réussi à naviguer avec laura comme ça et
je joue pas mal de petits caïds âme
celle de maths en un nom mais je pense
aussi défaut le fourrage est ce que
j'écris aussi est en fait moi je pensais
qu'il est d'amsterdam prend à vii mais
y'a pas puisqu'à la tour qui contrôlent
brassard ont fini well as a fait ça fait
plus 5 alors fait voir à quand le petit
1 14 buts
ils marchent plus bas ils ont plus mis à
jour en plus mis à jour quand le roi et
en d3 ça faisait matée par wade 4,3 sur
l'utilité comme toute façon il m'attend
n'a en fait moi j'ai cru qu'ils avaient
il y avait un moi c'était là en fait ah
oui ça fait mal
j'ai vu que le fouetter protéger mais
y'a des matins il a raté deux fois en
plus un terrible la plus celle aussi des
dames projet de jeu
oui parce que je pensais qu'il attaquait
le fou et qu'il allait planter un échec
en fait derrière hockey
bon qui sait que ça qu'il est à deux
doigts de matériaux
bon sens comme tata tout ça ouais mais
du let c'est le bullet c'est pas son
truc c'est tout bas la finlande a plus
de temps ton de panique
ouais ouais c'est pas son truc c'est pas
son truc à monsieur en même temps c'est
déjà le temps qu'il avait notre seconde
seconde éternité pour un m'attendre mais
il n'a pas pris et je veux tempo tempo
tempo mais c'est dur dompter cette
cadence de plus simple moi j'aime pas en
fait j'aime pas la jouer on va 10-4-1
+13 +1 j'aime bien mais un plus un je
n'aime pas trop je prends le bus là tu
vois ça ça m'arrive pote plus ça en fait
et toi je sais pas je mets journal le
sens nous avec baky quand on fait les
matchs ont fait du 1 + 0 1
ouais on n'est pas peut être en fait tu
peux plus bien joué à la fin non
est-ce que flag et non plus à quelle
hauteur voilà il va finir par la gagne
et quand même fabiano banon seconde
coulée se retourner mais oui il devrait
y crois que notre encore trouvé de
l'activité viens de faire deux coups
après s'active une position
catastrophique billet bien passé il ya
plus de resto chic y est c'est fini
puis tu as le roi qui arrive nice en
jambes et rappela que la claque et ça
roule c'est un libéro coincé chez pas il
monta font quoi
j'ai 3 il va y avoir un réseau de maths
avec le roi quoi c'est exceptionnel à
trois c'est terrible ces thèmes le
cavalier qui bloque et d'échecs du fou a
bien joué je vous prends françois
chérèque et on a gagné une
alors il reste quand il reste moins de
trois quatre parties
il reste quatre parties et à 4,5 en
gagner automatiquement
alors si ça non mais la rigueur tu vois
je préfère le truc de rajouter plus de
au 60e quitte à faire un truc comme ça
je fais bullet au 60e ya le plus de cas
arrive
ouais ouais je veux un truc on peut voir
plein de trucs comme ça
c'est bizarre tout ça passe et dure à
appréhender autres qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
d'où la charge avec une pièce de plus le
roi reste un peu ça ils auront au final
quatre points c'est ça ouais un peu plus
fort qu'un fou un cavalier mais un peu
moins fort qui le tour pourquoi pas si
bien joué ça méritait bien cette fille
est plein de gaz notamment celle là plus
ces 5 84 ans et 5 tu vas être heureux
puis à lui faire acheter des compagnies
s'appartient taillage de h5 f4 tout ça
pourrait bien être la partie décisive à
fab cavaliers 17 kg 4 car il y avait six
mois comme contre mosley
kamel style gbowee qui veut ça
quel style en sueur mais quatre ou cinq
noms tu t'installes bien et tu vois tu
rien nada major sacrifier que j'ai 4 h 5
mais bon je vais bientôt avisés de faire
fourrer fille 4 les bloquer samba sow le
faire trop france ti cats dames 3
probablement une bonne idée mais non
merci de te faire damer des six états
mais fuite on tira après que d'un
machisme qui est pas mal direct en tout
cas carnac qui se démène pour défendre
en tout cas clairement c'est un truc
tellement plus agréable jacques et blanc
genre truc
ouais après surtout car il ya six qui
aime arthur ici lors ils tendent
mais bon tu t'es mort d'au moins ouvrir
un peu le centre des arts et des lettres
5e petit ça fait peur c'est tf cette
fourchette
c'est terminé fabien officiellement
victoire victoire la plus 5 8 minutes
c'est impossible de revenir y aura
jamais cinq parties tes impressions fab
après après cette scène a eu une trop
forte
qu'est ce que tu penses contre west
l'eso est ce que tu vois
jean-christophe en capacité de créer la
surprise et retourner la table wei peu
mais moi je le trouve un peu favori mais
franchement ça dépend où qu'ils soient y
aura quoi c'est le souk on n'a vu
l'autre jour doudom favorite mais ce
sera pas le soir mon avis quand même vu
l'autre jour férié je pense sera so il
avait battu un saut duda télé l'année où
il avait surpris l'avait battu cariat
qu'ingrid choc et j'ai appris à sauvage
c'est trop tôt il avait défoncé il avait
pris très au sérieux il s'était jamais
faire tourner
extrêmement dans les sauts c'est un
sacré client et non ce genre de forme
carrée numéro 2 mondial après ce match
car oui ça match ne compte pas pour le
classement donc pourrait perdre 100 à 0
il serait numéro deux mondial match
compte pour rien folk en tout cas pour
ce tournoi il ya un titre en jeu à la
fin mais c'est toi
pas con classement à tous à bombay h4
qui saute et puis olivier plus c'est
normal le match et le match est plié fab
je peux le comprendre en plus quand le
match était serré avant c'est d'autant
plus dur à la fin il fait que des tricks
c'est chaque coup immédiat centriste uc
vous avez la prendre mais cédé quatre
coups que ça dure koch difficile pour
fabiano qui prend l'eau + 6
ouais mais ils étaient ils étaient moins
forts et alors après est-ce que s'il
avait réussi à conserver son avantage le
plus 4 + 5 méritant 5 + 1 il aurait pu
tenir en vue là tout pas c'est quelque
chose que j'aurais bien aimé voir -
fabiano je commence à +3 +4 tu vois et
qui se prend l'avalanche prêt à ladoux
da qui a filé une pièce les joueurs y
sont plus non plus hein le match est
fini
quel pied non mais oublie un truc ils
vendent à va 4 e coli a fait ça un après
il a récupéré son plus jeune âge j'ai vu
à laquelle disparaît j'ai compris qu'il
va truc
ouais avec john wayne
après quand on traque est finie suprême
ou stupre et move comme ça aussi je
pense que les deux joueurs en ont un peu
marre aussi quoi s ils ont envie que ça
se finisse et du coup non mais du coup
je savais pour caruana parce que fatigué
de figeac d'art pour rien
les plans c3 pour qui et b prends et je
suis content à structure là c'était
juste par akiva pour lui non ça serait
sympa ouais tiens mais qui permet un
bullet et du retard ils doivent
cravacher
mais ça veut dire 1,25 c'était cadeau 1
à 1 15 m ji sage tu sais jamais en fait
je pensais pas que j'étais sûr que
c'était j'ai toujours su j'ai toujours
dit d'ailleurs mais ouais c'était bon du
coup j'ai mis du dauphin vol pour le
match c'est sûr ça j'avais pas trop beau
yasar d'acheter en train de se chauffer
qui fait des échecs commence à parler
d'un event qu'il faut passer par les
bonnes causes plus importantes par
esprit là oui mais il fait des échecs là
5000 spectateurs
l'intérim est important et alors il joue
comment
j'ai pas encore fait training on a pas
mal discuté mais ouais je pense que je
pense qu'il va pas mal joué je pense
qu'il va pas mal joué puisqu'il jouait
quand il était gamin il à s'engager à
tout et me semble acquis je veux quand
tu étais petit naïf et des tactiques et
tous ses biens et 1600 tactique déjà ils
continuent ils étaient mille quatre cent
cinquante donc c'est progresser dans le
rush to which has pointe comme à fond
sans sueur parce qu'il va amener sa
commune mais vous êtes quand même un
cran dans les achats coin c'est de faire
des trucs pour les échecs plus populaire
est ou non il faudrait dix ans mon
premier personnes vers des missions
mercredi avec qui pense est une très
mauvaise idée
je pense qu'il faut mieux ne pas faire
landreau est vrai que j'ai l'impression
que dans les échecs
enfin vaut mieux avoir deux communautés
pas être connu ça à l'air d'être plus
plus résilient derrière la plus centrale
dans la communauté chilienne quand t'as
pas d'abonnés en fait c'est ces
centrales ne pas commenter
mais quoi dire non mais en fait on peut
pas se plaindre que les jacquet pas de
visibilité
il n'y a pas d'argent il n'y a pas si
y'a pas ça et quand il ya un truc à et
cracher sur les gens en ont avalé
troupes soit ce matin on a quand même le
droit de penser qu'à une commune
communauté immature ruyt alors il pense
alors à le penser mais je vois pas en
quoi c'est mal il va vous ramener sa
commune louis basse il ya des dizaines
voire des centaines gagnant des courses
investi à tout site achètent pas il a
une communauté énorme que tu as 50
verges dans ses échecs
ouais est ce qu'il va faire l'option
prend des 5 es tu vois la visite et à
quel prix mais ça va ça coûte rien en
fait enfin je n'avais pas non non par
contre quid dans beat par contre puisque
envie de bravo c'est la confidence et
netflix assez bien bah je crois pas
c'est vraiment la géométrie variable
suivant les gens coiffe assez
impressionnant toujours comme ça le deux
poids deux mesures c'est tout le temps
c'est n'est fixé bien s'harnache c'est
pas bien pourquoi on ne sait pas
terrible
c'est terrible normalement c'est très
bien mais excuses aux etats-unis c'était
bien aussi je fais tu ne sais pas enfin
qualitatif voix basse et c'est à
conduire le qualificatif subjectif c'est
ce qui est quitte pour certains ce n'est
pas pour d'autres et vice versa mais au
contraire c'est super positif et en plus
moi j'ai vraiment parler du coup une
heure en fait tu as heard of en vrai il
est vraiment sympa fatah plein de gens
qui te disent plein de trucs machins je
lui parle le gars est vraiment très cool
en fait je ne sais pas assez c'est
terrible non c'est toi qui n'était pas
sympa vraiment cool mais en fait c'est
comme moi quand je te lâchent un peu en
live et où les gens ils pensent qu'après
je suis comme ça tout le temps mais en
fait pas du tout non détrompe toi mais
il a dit cette chose en live sûrement il
le pensait mais c'est quand même hier
pendant le live amende maximum kouette à
dire qu'ils étaient obligés de réagir
dans chat ce que les gens pensaient
vraiment je guéris quinze ou vingt mille
euros par mois qu'avec avec les savait
toujours l'objet alors qu'enfin c'est
même pas la moitié enfin c'est n'importe
quoi même pas le quart d'ailleurs mais
aussi des troubles soient pas mon c'est
toujours pareil
mappy mais quand bien même tu rentres
milan fait jamal rue va tant mieux pour
toi en fait tu fais un truc ça marche tu
te bats depuis des années tu réussis bah
bravo enfin bien non mais les gens
partiront pas ils vont pas te parler des
six premières années où c'était 20
heures par semaine pour 0 quoi les gens
y vont non ça c'était normal en fait
mais c'était en fait on était mieux que
c'est dur 15 ans comme ça ça aurait été
beaucoup mieux mais bon tout le monde
sait que les quinze cas c'est vrai de
qui gagne quoi en fait enfin ce qui est
bien et gagnent de l'argent tant mieux
pour lui en fait je vois même pas le
problème
ce serait vrai si on enlevait ci ont
multiplié par 1,5 les seuls qu'on
enlevait les 30% de switcher 50% d'impôt
là ce serait vrai donc c'est heil en
fait mais c'est n'importe quoi mais je
leur paraît que c'est un peu le même
délire c'est beau un peu le même toit
enfin bon moi je dis tant mieux si ça
redonne chez nos échecs ça fait plaisir
et ça va ramener des gens au jeu et
c'est ça va faire parler encore plus d
échec et c'est génial
et en plus lui ça va c'est coûte pour
lui aussi joue aux échecs je sais pas
bah ouais non mais en fait c'est bien
joli jouera le temps qu'il a envie de
jouer
si ça lui plaît tout une entente très
bien s'ils jouent même que 2 - streiff
un peu importe c'est faugerat le positif
et pas toujours tout critiquer pour
critiquer quoi payer les gens qui
aimeront bien de clément - comme il ya
des gens qui aiment bien ce qui se passe
sur bis remote moins bon c'est comme ça
parce que chacun fait ce qu'il veut
après un bail à 8,1 sur le but latin
mais quel carnage
mais du coup il a fini à plus huit voix
gt gt même pessimiste avec +4 non mais
le 1 05 et est bien bien senti du coup
ce que je te propose c'est qu'on envoie
comme moi je penserai par stream faut
que je me repose un peu je pense mais
monsieur alors tenté de recentrer mais
bon là y'a trop de trucs je te propose
qu'on envoie un raid à sare dossche en
fait du coup ça vous fera les pieds y
est les bras les bras donc écoute je
propose qu'on fasse ça merci à tous
d'avoir suivi et puis ben allez suivre
sardasht préparez-vous quoi maintenant
il faut que le raid selon abc lançait
sportune même si un petit régal cents
spectateurs il va être heureux allez
merci à tous